foreign
can you hear me now okay thank you very
much
um my name is Rick Ladd I'm
representative from Haverhill I've been
chairing House Education here for a
number of years this is my seventh
Year's chair
and going on in my 15th year on this
particular committee and we often times
have to use this room for those bills
which we expect or may have a number of
people wanting to testify and so before
we go ahead into the hearing process I'd
like to go over some of the rules
associated with our ability to use this
room which is a very important room here
in the state of New Hampshire it's the
house of the people and in the general
court we have rules and I'm going to go
through a few of them right now if in
fact there's anything in the pockets
right in front of you where you're
sitting where of the person for you the
person that sits at that please don't
take any of that material we oftentimes
distribute there shouldn't be much there
today seeing we we're not having a
session this week nor are we having one
next next week in there food and drink
in the hall here we recognize that we
want to stay hydrated however the only
beverage allowed in the hall is water
so coffee is not allowed here Pepsi Coke
not allowed here in the house itself but
water yes and please you know do hydrate
as we go along all the house rules that
are here for the representatives and
when Senators come in as well are
applicable to us here today
so there be no signage in here
advocating your position or advocating
against your position there will be no
clapping showing of Expressions such as
that especially emotion and we also
don't want the clapping
uh
we also have rules where there's a
wearing of materials sometimes people
wear hats and all that with
literature in the Hat
Etc are not allowed
so just generally another thing that I
do always here when I'm running I'm
meeting an education that if we have a
parent showing up with children I
oftentimes will allow that parent with
those children to come up and speak as
they come so we can get the youngsters
out and back to what they need to be
doing I'm talking about young ones now
that are preschool and up through the
first Elementary grades right up through
about fifth grade we'll try to get
people Audi as quick as we can and also
there are some people that travel
extensive distances in our state down
for these hearings and I'm not seeing a
whole lot out here right now so I think
we're going to be good with that but
oftentimes I will try to get somebody
that's coming down from Pittsburgh or
Colebrook or up where traffic's pretty
heavy in the southern part of the state
a certain hours a day try to get them
out as well in a timely fashion
if we have testimony we've had some
testimony in the past where we've had
numerous pink cards in order to speak
today
there's a pink card similar to the one
I'm holding up right here if you want to
speak you need to have one of these
filled out and presented to the folks
out back in the ante room and they will
be brought down to us here at the well
so we can get you lined up
I will oftentimes also if a senator
walks in and wants to testify try to get
them up and have them present or state
what they want as quickly as possible we
have 24 senators in the state here of
which they are on not just one committee
they may be on two three or four
different committees and a lot going on
that particular day and they can't hang
around here for an hour and a half
waiting for their opportunity to speak
so we'll just put them right into the
queue and have them uh present their
position that applies it's applicable
also to our officials such as the
governor and and council members on the
governor's Council
I think that takes us through most of
what we're going to be doing today if
you're going to be testifying today and
if you have written testimony it's
appreciated if you do not go through and
read it verbatim try to summarize it and
then to leave a copy of that written
testimony so the written testimony can
be entered into the record
so we'll have that available and that
can be provided to the people out in the
ante room or dropped off here with one
of the Reps sitting in front of you here
the folks sitting out front are the
members of the House Education committee
we have 20 people on the house committee
and this year we have 10 Republicans and
10 Democrats on that committee so I'd
like to go ahead now and open up this
hearing this hearing is a hearing on HB
61.
yeah
and we do have copies of that available
not in this chamber here but they can be
available up in the clerk's office area
and they're also in the ante room as
well
so with that I'd like to open up and I'd
like to invite down our Prime sponsor of
this bill representative Peter Petrino
who is going to be introducing the bill
and one other thing we may at times ask
this room fills up go into time limits
however when I had the prime sponsor the
person that's responsible for
introducing this I oftentimes will give
a lot of latitude to the prime sponsor
so they have the ability to use more
than two three four five minutes if
that's necessary so welcome
representative
thank you Mr chairman you're welcome oh
I can be heard
and thank you members of the committee
I am representative Peter Petrino
from Hillsboro 43 the town of Milford
and I'm honored to present this
legislation for your consideration
my objective is to repeal provisions of
the law relating to the so-called
right to freedom from discrimination in
public workplaces and education
I'm beginning my third term in the house
previously I served as a high school
social studies teacher for 41 years
my wife Marie too was a retired
Elementary teacher
of 35 years
and the better part of our Circle of
Friends
consist of teachers
and I consider myself speaking today
more so as an educator
than I do as a legislator now in fact
last night I had a dream that I was back
at school and I couldn't find my
classroom
that's
that's the truth
well I taught for 19 years in an
all-boys Catholic High School
in my last 21 years in two New Hampshire
public high schools
I served for many years as the
department chair
supervising upwards to 13 teachers at a
time
I've interviewed and hired many teachers
along the way
I was the chair of my school district's
last complete revision of the K-12
social studies curriculum revision
and extensive documents that we worked
on for a number of years
and using the New Hampshire Department
of education's curriculum framework as
our guide
in all that time
in all my encounters with educators
from across the country
I never ever heard
of critical race Theory
or divisive Concepts never heard of it
in fact when I first heard of it just a
few years ago I had to look it up
and even then I wasn't exactly sure what
it was all about and I had to do more
research
so to be honest I really never
understood why there was need
for this law
in the first place
now those who support the law claim it
is meant to prevent discrimination in
schools and in the workplace however you
may recall that the original House Bill
focused exclusively on race and gender
and the governor made it clear that
there was no way he would support that
so it was later amended in the Senate to
include discrimination
of all kinds
as such
it was explained that with the amended
version
a school could not teach that
able-bodied people are inherently
oppressive against disabled people
that younger Americans broadly
discriminate against older Americans
that this notion is absolutely laughable
it's ludicrous so far-fetched no such
discussions as these examples occur in
the classroom those who went to the
profession are for the most part loving
caring compassionate and selfless
individuals far from being prejudiced
and discriminatory
the amended version was simply an
attempt to camouflage the Bill's
original intent
to prevent honest and open discussion on
matters of race and gender that some
people simply don't like
and they don't want disgust
the law has nothing to do with real
discrimination
or honest academic inquiry
instead the law was meant to silence
teaches voices
I'd like to go back to the days
when teachers were respected
23 years ago I stood here in this
chamber before the entire house
and received the standing ovation when
the speaker presented me with a
commendation for being named the New
Hampshire teacher of the year
I don't know when the last time was
that a New Hampshire teacher of the year
was presented before the house and
received such accolades certainly not in
the last four years that I have been
in the house
instead last year I sat in this room
and I heard a speech in which teachers
were referred to as groomers
what has happened over the years
where
has the respect
for the education profession going
teachers just want to teach as we always
have
without the interference of the states
without the fear of an Inquisition
or the loss of our credentials
all because maybe a student
misinterpreted the class discussion
or just wanted to be a crankster
as one of my former colleagues told me
that how during a lesson on the Civil
Rights Movement
one of her students said
Miss is this something I'm going to have
to report you on
it wasn't funny to her
it was just outright scary
even with the guidelines from the
Department of Education
teach is still wonder
if they can refer to the KKK
as an inherently racist group
how is an elementary teacher
who is celebrating Martin Luther King Jr
day with their students
supposed to respond when her first
grader asks
why why were some white people so mean
to black people
I've always understood that laws are
enacted to address pressing problems in
society
some would argue that there are much
greater concerns than the perceived
discrimination in the classroom and
workplace school shootings
being one instance
yet there are those who would not
sacrifice an inch of their second
amendment rights
to deal with the problem of school
shootings
so why then would we sacrifice our first
amendment rights of free speech to
stifle honest and open discussion in the
classrooms especially when there is no
urgent
clear in present danger
of a particularly disturbing nature
recently I and the co-sponsors of this
legislation
received an email
from the vowed racist
who called us Auntie White
for proposing this bill
and as he said
and I quote
kids are rejecting the critical race
Theory BS being taught in the classroom
and he spelled out the expletive
they are sick of being force-fed
anti-white hate and they are sick of end
behavior
wherever they look
and he spelled out the n-word
I want to make it very clear
that I am not suggesting that those who
support the current law are racist there
are many good people who sincerely
believe that the law is
anti-discriminatory
however there are racists as evident
from the email I received that believe
that the law promotes their agenda
there were those who would argue that
the sentiments expressed in that email
reflect the actual intent of the
original bill
to silence teaches voices
to suppress discussion on matters they
don't want disgust
those who truly love freedom are not
afraid
to have an honest and open exchange of
ideas
there is nothing more Un-American than
being close-minded and stifling free
expression
now some will say the teachers are wrong
they can still Teach as they always have
they will say the racists are wrong
that the law is actually meant to
prevent discrimination
what's really wrong is this law
and it's clear that there is a lot of
confusion and uncertainty and that alone
makes it a bad law
more so
it is an insult to every teacher
in a detriment to every student
and I ask for your consideration to
repeal this law
thank you very much for listening to my
testimony and I am happy to answer any
questions
thank you very much representative are
there questions from the committee
representative
thank you for taking my
question I I keep reading and rereading
through the law that you want to repeal
and I still am unsure what in the law
itself what in the wording
um
makes a teacher unable to teach about
slavery about racism about Martin Luther
King about the Civil Rights Movement
about being able to have honest
discussions because talking about a
topic and teaching that somebody is
inherently better than another
are two different things and so I'm
hoping you can enlighten me in what in
this bill what in this law actually
stops a teacher from teaching all of the
you know about all of those issues thank
you yes thank you for asking the
question
as I mentioned before I can't see why
there was a need for this law to begin
with because any of the concerns that
this law supposedly was supposed to
address was never an issue to begin with
the bottom line is this
regardless of what the law may or may
not say teachers are in fact very
confused the examples that I gave them
my testimony are real they're not made
up I hear it from my former colleagues
and friends all the time why do we have
this law can I teach this can I say that
and the Department of Education put out
a directive
and in it it uses the words inherently
racist tell me is the KKK inherently
racist can a teacher actually say that
does the teacher say hmm if I say that
in class like that student just kind of
being silly Miss is this something I
have to report you on is that something
really teachers want to have hanging
over their head maybe the law just needs
to be changed no maybe the law just
needs to go
okay
thank you very much further questions
from the committee
thank you very much representative thank
you
is representative Ammon in the
room to representative you're recognized
we now had the prime give the bill now
I'd like to have if you is there if
there is written testimony would you
please try to summarize and speak to
your your intent and your primary points
thank you
thank you Mr chair good morning members
of the committee
for the record my name is Keith Ammon I
represent Hillsborough District 42.
there's a lot of disinformation about
this law
and I thought one easy way to clear it
up and just to get this into the record
is to not read the whole
law that's looking to be repealed
but at least the The major portion of it
there are two sections of the law that
are going that that would be repealed
have if this bill passes and this is the
second attempt uh to try to repeal these
laws
the first one has to do with teaching on
discrimination
in the other section which is even a
larger section has to do with
the freedom from the Discrimination in
public workplaces
and education
so the these sections of law there's
repeating sections I won't have to read
the same thing over and over again
but I would like to start with uh
prohibit prohibition on teaching
discrimination this is what the law
actually says there's a lot of again
misinformation about this law
there's no such thing as divisive
Concepts in this bill so if you're
someone say that they're referencing
something that doesn't exist
it says no pupil in any public school in
the state shall be taught instructed
inculcated or compelled to express
belief in or support of any one or more
of the following
that one's age sex gender identity
sexual orientation race Creed color
marital status familial status mental or
physical disability religion or national
origin is inherently Superior to people
of any
of those other things
so no individual is inherently Superior
based on those traits
also that an individual by virtue of is
or her age sex gender identity sexual
orientation race Creed color marital
status familial status mental or
physical disability
religion or national origin is
inherently racist sexist or oppressive
whether consciously or unconsciously
again it's about the individual
it's not about a group of people it's
about individuals that an individual
should be discriminated against or
receive adverse treatment
solely or partly because of his or her
age sex
gender identity Etc
that people of one age sex gender
identity Etc
should not attempt to treat others
without regard to those same
characteristics
nothing in this section shall be
construed to prohibit discussing as part
of a larger course of academic
instruction the historical existence of
ideas and subjects identified in this
section
and then it goes on to say any person
who's aggrieved by a violation has a has
a recourse to try to work it out
so that's what the law actually says the
section on
prohibition of public employers applies
to teaching
instructing public Employers in their
workplace those same ideas
so we hear that this law is vague and
unclear
it seems very clear to me
the Department of Justice the Department
of Education and the Human Rights
Council has put out clear guidance
on how to
navigate this law for educators
they say it violates free speech
public employees have limitations by
Nature
on their freedom of speech
a teacher hired to teach history
can't teach math because they want to
they have to fulfill their role as a
public educator
they say it prohibits accurate teaching
of History it's clear in the law that it
does not
and they say it's unconstitutional
that matter is still an open question
there's a pending lawsuit as you may
know
that will decide that matter
we heard in September the judge would
issue
a ruling 30
or sorry 60 to 90 days
from September we still don't have that
ruling
but it could come any day now
and just it just to iterate
because someone files a lawsuit doesn't
make something unconstitutional
so the purpose of this law
is to foster a truly colorblind and
gender-blind society and make sure that
our children in school are being taught
those values
and that's the end of my testimony I'll
take any questions
are there questions from the committee
yes representative Ellison
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh you just made a
statement about clear guidance on this
which was coming from the New Hampshire
Department of Education if in fact the
guidance is clear why are we hearing so
many stories from teachers that it's not
clear and they don't know what to do
I guess I would ask rhetorically
what have they done to engage the
Department of Education to clear up
those uncertainties
um
unfortunately
there is uh a need
among some to try to instill
something called Collective guilt
where
they they think it's important
teach some kids that because of the way
they were born they should feel guilty
about it
and
it could be
that that's the source of the confusion
the law states that we treat everyone as
individuals regardless of those
characteristics
there's nothing clearer than that to me
when you start mixing it up
with your group identity that's where
the confusion comes in
does that make sense
thank you thank you very much further
questions from the committee thank you
very much representative thank you
I'd like to have representative Tim
Horrigan
representative Horgan I see you put down
four minutes can you keep down to about
three oh that's right yes thank you very
much uh thank you Mr chair so I'm
representative Tim hawer again from the
town of Durham
um
first of all although this I should be
shortening my remarks my previous uh
representative made a comment about
Collective guilt and that struck home
for me because
um although the Oregon side of my family
not can also so pedigree came over in
the mid 19th century pretty much uh
stayed out as much as they could out of
the Civil War and inspires they were on
the pro-union and anti-slavery side of
it but my mother's family was very much
divided and in fact I probably
wouldn't have been here if not
um
if not the house slaves in Tennessee who
are looking after my great-grandfather's
family including my great-grandfather
had not uh warned them of a that John
Brown was coming and they would have
been killed along with a number of other
people at the slave rebellion so I've
got a certain amount of collective guilt
guilt there so and I accept that slavery
is part part of our history
um
so it takes out all the divisive
language enter the law book by section
297 of chapter law 2021 better known as
hb2 the Budget Trailer bill and the
first language that language may appear
to be anti-discriminatory but is in fact
racist sexist ableist and every other
type of big hit basically perpetually
the myth that everybody you know isn't
like me you know I'm white male
Christian
Etc are pretty much
the generic white male human being in
every regard
um
we're but there's people come in all
shapes sizes and colors and that's a
good thing and
so but we can't actually have a gender
blind Society even sounds like an
idealistic thing but that's actually uh
you know not not fair to those who are
uh say gender identity other than mine
which they call CIS male um
they have I talked about the legislative
history my written testimony actually I
left out
and I type out it was originally
sections 330 and 331 of the houses where
is the Budget Trailer development acts
before that was HP 544
um there's a bill sponsored in 2021 by
the member from New Boston he just spoke
also the uh majority leader who was also
the majority leader back then and the
vice chair of the committee so fair is
there were some fairly uh high-powered
members of the majority caucus behind it
and um
that mostly dealt with the operation of
state agencies he kind of at least
ostensibly dealt only in passing and
education so I'm actually going to just
argue that HB 61 may have been sent to
the wrong committee at HB 544 actually
went to Edna we had a rather interesting
hearing which I participated in Edna
and actually
what the Senate put in section 297 of
the Budget Trailer Bill and I'm sure I'm
like boring you I'm sure like your eyes
are glazing over at all these uh section
numbers that was actually put in by the
Senate and that language
um it's almost it's mostly about the
commission on human rights and
restricting uh what it can do so that
really they'll probably arguably should
have been the committee I said on
Judiciary but here we are and I'm happy
Judiciary is going to have over 80 bills
I'm happy not to have another bill so
does have one section related to
education and that
section is especially egregious um our
state and our nation can't cannot be
great unless our students know our Real
History you know including the uh less
Savory more unpleasant side of the of
that history which I alluded to at the
beginning of my remarks
and HB 19340 effectively prevents the
public schools from teaching that
history and
um I actually would have preferred
taking out all the bills the last one
193.40 they put an amendment they serve
like uh just revise the language to make
it say the opposite of what the original
Bill said and that's fine I can live
with that I would have heard just
deleting it funny one very very small
irony
of each which is carried over from
representative Oregon you've gone well
over three minutes now can you try to
conclude yeah marks I'll wrap up one
more thing there was nothing
uh there's nothing last time which
prevented educational providers who are
subsidized by tax paid School vouchers
from teaching so-called divisive
Concepts and
these providers are actually not uh
mentioned in the revised language of uh
of this bill because it is leaving one
part remaining although changing the
meaning to me the opposite was intent
it's not just sort of a small irony of
the legislation that we're overturning
but just thought I'd bring it up so
thanks for your patience and
if anybody wants to ask me any questions
they're welcome to although the chair
would probably are there any questions
from the committee
not see any thank you very much thank
you very much for listening thanks
I'd like to call Representative Maria
Perez
good morning remember
good morning
good morning members of the committee
and members of the public
my name is Maria Perez
I'm a state representative from District
43 Milford New Hampshire
buenos dias Mi nombre es Maria Perez
solar representante is
Milford New Hampshire
is
salvadorena
foreign
representative who represent District 43
that's how I want to start my testimony
I'm hearing support to this bill first
of all because in my background it's a
human relations
for
um
a big Corporation for almost 11 years
in an assistant administrator for almost
five years for another big company in my
town
it is critical for people like myself
who work in an industry that we deal
with different backgrounds religions
languages
hurdles
is critical for us to learn
why people come here why people
sometimes don't want to talk why people
sometimes cry why people
need support and it workplace and it's a
cultural relations why sometimes
customers they have a hard time speaking
to someone
for example I would work I work in a
dealership for many years
is critical for us
when I went to college I'm so grateful
that I learned
by studying sociology
cultural anthropology the background of
many people
the suffering
for example a lot of times when we did a
presentation in my school
they asked for us to give in
I'm honest opinion why do you think
immigrants come here for me it was
critical and it I'm so grateful that I
have the opportunity to share
that I move here because of the word and
El Salvador that I used to hire
underneath my bed for many days with no
food no water
just try to protect my life
and it's good for me to share the good
part of my life too that I have a
brother who's a famous artist Jose Raul
Alfaro he's a artist who paint a
beautiful oil paints
this is the things that we want to share
I don't want people to try to erase my
history or the history of many of us
that we've been here for so long
many of us who provide and many of us
that we try to be part of this Society
what I'm asking you this committee is to
support this bill
we're not trying to say I'm better than
you or you better than me
we only want respect and to find
finalize my testimony
I got an email from a white supremacy
group here in New Hampshire
calling me a mestiza let me tell you
mestiza is someone who comes from
my father he wasn't he was born in the
same my man she's an indigenous person
I'm proud to be a mestiza that person
tried to offend me and they told me that
I need to go back to Mexico or the
country that mestizos that looked like
me We Belong to they told me that my
family doesn't belong here that we need
to go back where we came from
that they don't want us here let me tell
you something I'm here to say I'm here
to stay because I have a work to do I'm
here to stay because I need to keep
representing my people in Milford I'm
here to stay because my voice is needed
voices are people who look like me they
they've been they need it on this day
because people need to realize that
we're not here to take away your rise
we're not here to take advantage of the
country we're here to give it back to
the community thank you so much for your
time thank you very much representative
are there questions for the
representative
yes representative
first I want to say I'm glad you're here
and I'm glad you're going to stay
um but I have the same question for you
that I had for the sponsor which is what
in the law that
this bill tries to repeal keeps you from
saying those things or for from talking
at work about the oppression that you
suffered the oppression that you suffer
now any of that what in the law keeps
that from happening because I don't see
it I see the law as protecting you from
somebody saying they're better than you
because of their color
sex whatever and so I'm not
understanding can you explain to me
please yeah I'm more than happy to
explain to you since this Lord was
passed they give the right to people
like the these groups who sent me an
email to be more open to discriminate
against us to be more open to call us
whatever they want to call us and give
the right to people in the community to
told teachers if I don't like why you're
teaching
please parents report the teachers and
we pay you 500 to report a teachers
because we don't like what you're saying
we don't like what you teach
how can we tell a teacher they owe we
have a clear language when teachers are
so afraid when people in the public put
in we pay you 500 to report a teacher
that is teaching something that'll make
you uncomfortable oh now that we have
people in the community saying
oh we only have two genders and we have
only that she and he not they then
never before before these bill was
passed people have the right or they
feel so comfortable about discriminate
about the lbdt community about people
who call her about different backgrounds
but now they feel they have the right to
be whatever they want to be and they
want to call us whatever they want to
call never before this bill that
happened that's why we need your support
to this bill
yes everyone say the language is clear
but it's not because it's these things
are happening and I see it in my own
community and I hear from teachers that
I hear from people in the community that
discrimination is happening after this
bill was passed
thank you very much representative
further questions from the committee
Nazi thank you very much
uh Holly Stevens
is Holly here
I believe she's also a representative
but she has down Nami New Hampshire
okay
Emma sabigny
good morning good morning I have written
testimony as well I don't know you could
drop a copy off either with right down
here at the corner or
or outside in the ante room
thank you that that helps
thank you representatives for hearing
Our Testimony today on this important
bill
um I am Emma savini I am the children's
Behavioral Health policy coordinator at
new Futures which is a non-profit
nonpartisan organization that Advocates
educates and collaborates for the health
and wellness of all Granite Staters
today I'm here to talk in support of
House Bill 61
because it is a
a great way we can take a step forward
as a state
to improve the learning and exploration
of these
race gender diversity topics in our
state and in our schools and in our
workplaces that will help build a more
healthy safe and Equitable place that we
all envision
um it's known that inequities
disproportionately affect the well-being
of populations protected against
discrimination in our state
unfortunately many of these
discriminatory policies and
discrimination inequities relate to
poverty and contribute it contribute to
Poverty for our children and families
poverty is one of the most dangerous
threats to our children's behavioral and
mental health
that children face today
however giving children a simple space
and safe area for them to explore these
topics learn about these topics in an
age appropriate way and express the
challenges that they're facing can help
improve and Empower them to make changes
they would like to see in the world this
sense of empowerment can lead to better
outcomes for health and mental health
and better financial and educational
opportunities as well
by giving children this safe space to
talk in our schools we have the ability
to make sure our children feel heard
seen and welcome in our communities for
all Granite State children
House Bill 61's repeal of the old bill
will remove the chilling effect that the
the current law as it stands has on on
children and teachers from being able to
discuss these topics freely in an
age-appropriate manner in their
classrooms
new Futures off uh recommends and
encourages the committee to vote ought
to pass on this bill
thank you very much are there questions
from the committee
not seeing any thank you
like to welcome Deb Nelson
hope you had a good drive down from
Hanover yes okay
I went slowly
thank you members of the committee I am
reading this because
it's easier for me my name is Deborah
Nelson and I live in Hanover where I
currently serve on the Hanover and
Dresden school boards although I am not
speaking today on behalf of either board
I do however want the committee to know
that both the Dresden and Hanover School
boards unanimously passed a resolution
months ago against the divisive Concepts
bill I think it's fair to note that
there have been many education bills
proposed and voted on over the last two
years that are deeply concerning to
school boards parents students members
of the community and especially teachers
until I recently retired I taught
American studies for three decades in
New Hampshire's public school system
one important goal was to educate my
students about America's past and to
examine various periods in history with
a critical eye I encourage my students
to question to read multiple sources of
information and to draw connections when
appropriate between the past and the
present
we used to watch a video during our
study of the McCarthy period that
included an interview with a New
Hampshire teacher
who recalled worrying that something she
said at the time might prompt students
to report her and that she could lose
her job
I remember my students being appalled by
what they thought was her paranoia
and I had to clarify that class
discussion could be reported to outside
groups and teachers could be punished
and lose their jobs although I reassured
them that those days were in the past
imagine my dismay to learn that those
days are back
since the passage of what we refer to as
the divisive Concepts bill and the
attendant
no doubt deliberate uncertainty over
what teachers can and cannot teach what
works they can and cannot assign what
discussions can and cannot take place
New Hampshire classrooms have
experienced a great deal of turmoil it
seems some legislators think that
students benefit from what I am calling
narrowed history yet high school
students in particular thrive on
complication they Delight in Nuance they
are curious about mistakes in history
and they quickly see through efforts to
shut away information and limit access
ask any parent of a teenager ask any
parent of a curious child ask any
teenager and they will tell you this is
the stuff of learning I think it's
dangerous therefore to suggest that
students should not learn about both the
positive and negative elements of our
past in thinking about the curriculum my
colleagues and I taught I'm struck by
the number of topics that could now be
seen as inappropriate or complicated
the Cherokee removal and the Trail of
Tears labor history such as the Triangle
Shirtwaist fire the homestead steel
strike can students study political
cartoonists such as Thomas Nast herblock
Walt handelsman can they learn that
Supreme Court Justice Hugo Black was a
member of the KKK
can they learn the problems with
Hoover's presidency the Gulf of Tonkin
the Bay of Pigs father coughlin's hate
radio in the 1930s Stonewall riots AIDS
policies
the list goes on and on
we used to read the jungle and discuss
how it influenced Teddy Roosevelt to
push for passage of the Pure Food and
Drug Act which created the Food and Drug
Administration but the book was first
published in serial form in the
Socialist magazine the appeal
so does that make it tricky
at what point will teachers simply give
up and leave the classroom all together
yesterday's Washington Post includes an
opinion article I recommend to you all
the first two sentences ask who will be
left to educate this country's children
when all the teachers have had enough
who will remain when Educators Tire of
picking their way through a political
obstacle course of manufactured
controversies about racial Justice end
quote
the vagueness of the language in the
current bill threatens to stifle the
very critical thinking and reflection
which we should be celebrating I've
spoken with former colleagues about the
new reality under which they teach and
they are understandably afraid one of
them a former student of mine
said each day she wonders
is this the classroom discussion that
will get me in trouble
is this the day I get the phone call or
the email and we are talking about the
current language
it raises concerns it leaves people on
Shaky Ground
and she does skip over certain topics
and she is more guarded
we are the United States of America and
we need not fear providing information
and encouraging classroom discussions
our students are smart and resilient and
we do not damage them when we encourage
them to think
equally important our teachers are
working so hard to prepare students for
an Ever more complex world
as a child growing up during the Cold
War I lived in Baghdad
as well as an East and West Africa where
my father worked to support Democratic
principles and to encourage governments
to follow the model of the United States
rather than that of the at the time
Soviet Union
and I cannot begin to imagine the dismay
that he would Express over this recent
dismantling of the core principle of a
democracy which is a strong public
education
I urge the committee to step back from
the forces who wish to diminish public
education to threaten teachers with
punishment and to stifle learning in the
classroom I urge you to support House
Bill 61. thank you very much are there
questions from the committee
yes
I know what you're going to ask
good can you
on the surface that seems like a
reasonable question
it seems like the text is
straightforward and yet there are
bounties that have been established by
right-wing groups and yet the Department
of Education has made very clear that it
sees itself in an adversarial position
with public school teachers and
administrators that doesn't make sense
if the language is so easy
why is there a problem
and the problem is because under the
surface of that seemingly open language
there are dark Forces that want to
dismantle any conversation about race
gender identity
equal rights
it may not have been the intention of
those who wrote the Bill I don't happen
to believe in that particular train of
thought but the reality is that language
has led to significant problems in the
classroom that didn't exist when I was
in the classroom
that's the reality of the current
language
like it or not
people do feel Under Pressure teachers
do feel examined they do feel guarded
because what is to prevent a student
from saying as you discussed this
historically racial tense issue moment
I as a student felt discriminated
against
I as a white student felt that
conversation made me uncomfortable
everybody is uncomfortable when we talk
about race they should be
everybody should be uncomfortable when
conversations come up about a whole
range of things about our past we are
not perfect we have encouraged all kinds
of horrible actions towards immigrants
towards Catholics towards Jews towards
gay people if as a teacher you are
trying to help your students be more
empathetic more prepared to live in a
complex world you examine those elements
and then a student decides uh done with
that you're putting me in a place I
don't feel comfortable I'm going to
report you to the Department of
Education how many times
should that happen
what does that do to morale how does
that undermine a teacher
trying to have those good conversations
I will be honest with you very little
intimidated me when I was teaching
I was fine having those complicated
conversations I was fine when the
principal called me in I was fine
with all sorts of issues that came up
maybe it's because I'm tall maybe it's
because my father brought me up that way
maybe it's because
I just don't
roll over easily but that's not the case
for a lot of people teaching is hard
parents can be mean
in the 30 years though that I taught at
Lebanon High School could you please
wrap it up
thank you I never had a single complaint
from a parent about what I was teaching
not once
thank you very much and apologies thank
you very much
um we have gone now about 45 minutes and
we're averaging close to seven to eight
minutes per per testimony we're going to
have to cut that down
or else we're going to end up having to
recess this uh around 12 30 1 o'clock we
have other bills scheduled in in the
other building over here so I am going
to start putting the timer on and I'm
going to put it at three minutes when it
goes I'm going to ask that you wrap it
up this will be applicable to everybody
that's going to be testifying from this
point forward thank you I'd like to
invite Michelle Vesey
Michelle
I hope I am pronouncing your name right
okay
good morning and thank you very much for
allowing me to testify I'm Michelle
veazey and I'm the executive director of
New Hampshire businesses for social
responsibility so I'm here to testify on
behalf or give the business voice to
this bill I am here in support of hb61
and I will give you the reasons why
businesses are looking are are investing
tremendous capital in their workplaces
doing diversity equity and inclusion
training they're working to try create
more Innovative and inclusive workplaces
where we can address competition
challenging problems that we have in
this state right now we are a state
surrounded by others that are far more
Progressive in terms of our work in the
Dei field as Baby Boomers like myself
are aging out and leaving the workflow
Force our businesses are challenged to
bring enough new workers into the
workplace we need to have students who
are future Workforce come in with the
skills to critically assess issues and
to your question that is why we oppose
this bill it's important for teachers to
be able to explore the systems that are
in place around a problem because that's
the type of assessment that we're
looking for when they come into the
workplace we need employees that are
able to understand the problems address
them and creatively come up with
solutions that work for everyone and we
are working to create a more inclusive
workspace and we believe that teachers
are trying to create an inclusive
classroom and for that reason it is very
important to have the freedom to be able
to discuss these issues and assess them
the the dark history that we need to
assess we need to make sure that we
don't repeat the mistakes that we've
made in the past and that we move
forward with a more united country so
thank you very much and I'll yield my
time to the next person thank you very
much you're giving back about 55 seconds
all right
are there any questions from the
committee
it's not saying thank you oh and I I I'm
sorry if it wasn't clear I think I I
support hb61
okay we we've have a representative just
came into Hall and I know that they have
other meetings that got represented uh
Jonah wheeler
we've talked often about you're from
Peterborough absolutely we talked on the
horn the other day I think Peter has
mentioned meeting you a couple of times
welcome I thank you for letting me speak
I'll be as quick as possible I didn't
prepare a testimony but I did just want
to tell the committee really quickly
that as a third grader I had a bit of an
identity crisis I grew up to a white
mother in a white Community with no one
who looks like me anywhere near me I
didn't know my history I didn't know
where I came from who I was or what my
people have done to help build this
great nation of ours because of that
because of that identity crisis it made
it really hard to feel confident in
going out and being a human being being
someone who can live a full life and if
it wasn't for my third grade teacher who
took me aside in the middle of the third
grade class right before we learned
about civil rights and sat me down and
said this is your history this is your
story I need you to pay attention I need
you to listen and I need you to work
hard to understand it because without
this without your history then you won't
be the full person that you're meant to
be in this world I think of the kids who
are in conval right now the kids who are
across this state who are like me who
have a history that needs to be told
that needs to be taught to them yet
don't have it and if teachers feel that
they are able to tell that history to
their students if I didn't have a third
grade teacher who was willing to go out
of her way to make sure that I learned
and listened to my history that I very
well wouldn't be here in front of you
today and I know many people here in
this audience and across the state
wouldn't be the same person they are or
here today at all so I urge this
committee to protect our history to
allow schools to have full and
full-throated and comprehensive
discussions on what this country has
done and what our full history is
because without understanding where we
have come and where we are we will never
know where we're going and I want us as
a country to come together and to be
unified and to to move forward together
but we're not going to be able to do
that if we don't understand our full
history as it happens so I urge the
committee to support legislation not
just hb6 not just to oppose hb61 but to
support legislation throughout your term
here in this committee to make sure that
we're having a comprehensive discussion
on history and learning it as it
happened so thank you Mr Kevin I'll take
any questions if there are any thank you
very much representative wheeler
question yes
I just thank you for coming and that's a
very good testimony you gave
um
great third grade teacher it sounds like
I just want to Echo
representative lexus's question what in
just because this is important to me too
to understand
what in uh RSA 19340 Pro would prohibit
the teaching of the concepts that you're
talking about well I think the speaker
not right before me but the woman in the
blue vest Illustrated that well but I
think from my perspective having worked
with the teachers talked to many of them
specifically that teacher who had helped
me in third grade but also other social
studies teachers who are in my home
District of commval they as soon as this
legislation was introduced two years ago
felt a chilling effect in their schools
they had Parents contacting them asking
to illustrate the entire curriculum to
them that's accessible to that you're
stopping people's ability to teach and I
think the chilling effect that was felt
by simply introducing this legislation
is evidence enough to show where we
could go if the legislation was fully
implemented thank you thank you further
questions
thank you and have a good day thank you
chairman lad you as well you're welcome
say hi to representative Leachman for me
next uh individual is Joanne Kelly
thank you and thank you committee my
name is Joanna Kelly I'm a small
business owner in the assistant mayor in
Portsmouth New Hampshire and I'm also a
practically LifeLock Granite Stater I
moved here when I was six years old and
have gone through the whole education
system here I'm here to testify and
support not only as myself but as the
assistant mayor in Portsmouth of hb61 we
are racial Justice municipality and
for that
I am here to say that what we need to
make sure that we are doing here in
education in New Hampshire is making
sure that we are explaining and allowing
students to discover all narratives of
History we know that history has not
just hold in a black and white story or
in the ages in the ageism story it is in
the U.S our history is essentially a
five-lane highway where people are
allowed to get off and get on at
different points in time and we need to
make sure that what we don't do is limit
that down we need to make sure that
history is told through multiple
narratives in every possible way we need
to make sure that we are instilling in
our students and in our future Granite
Staters their ability to amass their own
critical thinking to allow them and
challenge them in ways that I believe
the bill that this will repeal has
limited them we need to allow and Trust
in our Educators that they know what
they're doing better than as someone who
writes policy sometimes better than we
write policy we need to make sure that
we are growing our community we make
sure that we are growing together as a
state we're in a critical time here in
the United States and in our country as
many speakers have told and as I have
experienced as myself racism is real in
our state it doesn't look it's an
unfortunate reality
and we have to make sure that we do not
allow vagueness we do not allow these
whether right ring or incels groups
to
to stop who we really are
we need to promote inclusivity we need
to promote these tough conversations and
as a business owner I do that we have
Open Door policies where we talk about
race gender social economic issues and
these are all things that I believe are
targeted in the bill that needs to be
repealed so I yell thank you thank you
very much other questions
now see any thank you
like to invite Al Brandon
I didn't know if there's an O at the end
of the your your last name I hope I got
it right no it's fine Grand Dental okay
um I Rise Against The against this bill
and I Rise Against this bill for three
reasons one uh it's poorly written in
nebulous
as described in the analysis the
analysis of the bill is what has me
really concerned uh especially the part
about our current experiences of any
group
that is protected in the discrimination
the second part I Rise Against is how
many teachers or businesses have been
prosecuted who's been prosecuted have
business people been prosecuted have
teachers been prosecuted by the
Department of Justice or the Department
of Education I don't believe so
um businesses have unions teachers have
unions have ways to be protected but the
only way to protect the parents is the
legislature that's your job we have no
one to protect us but you
um this bill will not stop uh hurt
feelings for being hurt
it won't create safer spaces
or it even won't stop identity crisis
the only one proven way to do that was
Dr King and he told us it was character
over color
I hate to say this but we need to go
back to the future that's where we all
need to be
and lastly we're not going to unite
anybody by calling or referring to
people as doc forces who may be against
this bill it doesn't help build Unity
thank you
thank you very much are there questions
from the committee
thank you very much
next individual is Pamela lenote
well that's an S excuse me
we have a bill in on cursive writing
but this is one of the nicest curse of
writing I've seen
so and you'll love this I 90 seconds
thank you
um
I'm presenting testimony in favor of
hb61
this past fall while waiting for service
at a garage a male customer and I struck
up a conversation
I learned that he'd been a public school
teacher in the Concord area for many
years
he was just over five years away from
retirement and was was looking forward
to it
he went on to tell me about the changes
not for the better that he'd seen over
the past few years and said that sadly
he wasn't enjoying the job as much as he
used to
he talked about the negative
psychological impact on kids of both the
pandemic and social media
and how this is made teaching more
challenging
he told me about experiencing a lack of
respect Often by kids but also some
parents
I got this sense he was a good committed
teacher who had indeed once loved his
job
I think we all know that today's
teachers are up against it in numerous
ways
if New Hampshire wants to attract and
retain good ones teachers need to be
able to work in an environment that is
supportive not distrustful and punitive
if you agree I urge you to vote to
support HB 61 and I happen to be a
clinical social worker good to say that
thank you and I apologize for not
stating your name correctly it's okay
okay the next person we have is Kristen
Schultz
she here there welcome hi thank you
I'm here as a former High School career
educator as a former vice president of
secondary education from my local
as a former vice president with aft
Massachusetts and as a sitting School
Board member with caresage regional
district though I'm representing myself
and I am here in complete support of
house bill 61.
the divisive Concepts law sensors
learning by prohibiting facts of history
and social realities from being
discussed discussed in schools in doing
so this law creates a narrow and perhaps
an accurate understanding of past and
present social and Civic realities that
are at odds with 21st Century Learning
where the divisive Concepts law applies
it Narrows or eliminates students
connections between content and their
personal experiences and or the real
life world
it eliminates research and intellectual
exploration of topics that would produce
facts that could fall under the device
of Concepts law and it Narrows higher
order thinking and the application of
Bloom's taxonomy and that students are
not able to explore synthesize and apply
critical thinking skills on topics that
could perhaps fall under the law but are
nonetheless extremely relevant and
Academia and in real life
and passing House Bill 61 New Hampshire
students and teachers will be able to
engage with school board approved
curricula and safe learning environments
when students and teachers feel safe
they feel comfortable taking academic
risks that promote and expand learning
moreover teachers will be able to
develop lessons designed for inclusion
so that each student may find in his or
her learning experience personal
connections to truth both past and
present
it's through access to Accurate unbiased
uncensored age and developmentally
appropriate content and with purposeful
scaffolding of that content through the
grade levels that students learn to
become critical independent thinkers
lastly in repealing the divisive
Concepts law you will be ensuring that
our students have access to the same
educational skills Concepts and
experiences that make them competitive
and educationally on par with their peer
groups around the country
with unabridged access to appropriate
and factual educational content and
experiences our students will have the
requisite Knowledge and Skills to
succeed in colleges in the trades and
our job markets and in society and I
implore you to pass House Bill 61
because our students Futures depend upon
it
exactly three minutes good job
are there any questions from the
committee
it's a new iPhone I have up here the
other one had 3G and it wouldn't work
down here so now I had to get the 5G and
spend another 700 something dollars
so I'd like to go ahead and invite Sean
Parr
Sean here yes
good morning good morning good morning
uh Mr chairman and members of the
education committee my name is Sean Parr
I'm on the Manchester School Board where
I serve on the policy committee as and I
also am the chair of the education
legislation committee I'm also a college
professor and a lifelong educator I've
taught math computer science Humanities
and music today I'm speaking on my own
behalf in strong support of house bill
61. this bill would repeal language that
currently prevents our students in New
Hampshire from having a full opportunity
to learn a complete picture of history
in its ramifications and how exactly
does this language hurt our students in
this way and this may help to address
representative lekkas's concerns with
vague and conflicting language it
confuses what teaching is allowable is
allowable under the law passages such as
those that ban teaching about inherently
oppressive Behavior quote whether
consciously or unconsciously is
confusing despite the guidance that the
Department of Education released to
interpret these confusing passages
teachers remain hesitant and even afraid
to discuss Concepts such as racism
reparation sexism and implicit bias and
understandably so for the 2021 law
allows anyone who claims to feel
aggrieved by such teaching to initiate a
civil action against the school
this threat limits the history that
instructors feel comfortable teaching
and it's so stressed our teachers that
they fear that teaching anything that
could be interpreted as polarizing or
divisive could end their careers
teachers deserve the freedom to explore
controversial topics in class as they
help our children to learn the
importance of basing their
interpretations on rigorous research to
learn how thinking critically and
evaluating The credibility of their
sources is crucial to understanding not
only history but the Maelstrom of
current events as well
troublingly because of its punitive
suggestions the 2021 language has also
interrupted the important work of
training our public employees
um
to have a to excuse me to understand
implicit or unconscious bias this
training is desperately necessary
because unfortunately studies and
current events have proven that real
world discrimination continues and is
widespread and awareness and
understanding of implicit bias is a
first step in overcoming the tendency to
discriminate for implicit biases our
brain's tendency to look for patterns
and make generalizations leading
stereotype confirming thoughts to pass
spontaneously through our minds and even
though it's really not fun to think that
we might not be behaving nicely we need
to reckon with this discomfort and learn
and do better we all could benefit from
implicit bias training and we all would
benefit from learning history that
doesn't avoid the tough controversial
topics
but teachers don't feel comfortable
doing that when their livelihood and
integrity are threatened that's why hb61
must be passed we need to restore trust
we need to trust our teachers as
professionals and we need to trust our
educational system our schools have
teachers and leaders who are charged
with providing our children a high
quality learning experience their work
is based on research on best practices
and we must allow our teachers the
freedom to really teach anything else is
a disservice to our students please pass
HP 61 thank you thank you very much are
there questions from the committee
now see thank you
uh Reverend John Hopkins
so Reverend here representing Concord
Lutheran
good morning good to see everybody thank
you for allowing me to speak this
morning I'm a Pastor Jonathan Hopkins
I'm the pastor of Concordia Lutheran
Church here in Concord also a member of
our church as a member of the Granite
State organizing project
uh I know there's going to be a lot of
people that are going to come up and
they're going to tell you why this is a
that this bill is a good idea
because of their teacher they're an
educator and those people know more
about such things than I do so I will
let them speak for themselves my field
is spirituality and I want to tell you
this morning why I think this is a bad
Bill spiritually
for a long time it's been said in our
society that you shouldn't talk about
politics or religion
you can imagine for me especially the
religion part is rather difficult
since that's my job but I think even the
politics part is difficult we have done
ourselves a disservice it's been a
detriment to society that we avoid these
topics and other uncomfortable topics
because we have not learned and not
taught our children how to talk about
difficult subjects with people we
disagree with on a fundamental level
who believe that hurts us spiritually
part of a good spiritual practice is
learning how to have difficult
conversations with people you disagree
agree with good spiritual practice leads
us to speaking with thoughtfulness and
kindness good spiritual practice leads
us ultimately to the truth
and we cannot have truth without good
vigorous debate
the other spiritual problem is that we
will never be able to fix any problems
we face without confession no human
endeavor and human history has been
perfect all nationalities all political
political beliefs all religious beliefs
are tainted with human imperfection
and this includes our country there's
never been a perfect president Congress
or Supreme Court we've never lived up to
the highest ideals of our national
creeds and we can only begin to fix the
problems of our country by first
realizing where we have gone wrong
confession is good for the soul and it
leads to the truth of who we are and who
we want to be I would argue that by
trying to deny
our past sins we are doomed to repeat
them in the future
and for the purpose
of confession and forgiveness does not
lead us to shame but rather frees us so
that we can move forward I ask you vote
ought to pass on hb61 so that we can
talk to one another about the past so
that we can hear different different
views we can see our past mistakes and
working together to make a more perfect
union thank you for your time thank you
very much Reverend are there questions
yes one representative
I'm just curious read the law that is
being talked about repealing I said it
again I'm sorry
excuse me I didn't hear your question oh
have you read the piece of law that they
are talking about repealing
have I read the law yes
you have yes
and
you need a question right here what you
need a question
I I heard you say and that's two
questions sorry can I ask the next
question very quick one
very quickly you you're talking about
freedom of speech you know to talk and
repent and whatever and I'm just
wondering what since you have read that
bit of law what in it would stop
somebody from being able to speak or
repent or discuss difficult things I
think others have already spoken about
that and I think they're smarter than me
on that so I will let their word stand
as mine
for years I was hoping for your event
thank you
um I'm going to take a I just want to
say I'm a pastor I'm not a politician so
okay uh I'm also on another committee uh
which is dealing with the teacher
shortage issue in the state here and we
had just walk in the room here and I'm
going to invite them all up front uh for
a second and uh allow them a few minutes
here to present their their position
um
okay it's a little sheet here Tina
philibotti Rachel uh Blanchett
Quincy Worthy
and Andre Maya
there's four right and what they are is
they're working in the area of diversity
Equity inclusion Justice and they're
employed by school districts here in our
state of New Hampshire so welcome again
I've spoke with you before I've seen you
on the that committee uh I'll give you a
speak to this bill please if you would
and let's try to get through it
cooperatively if we can within a very
short period of time here we get to move
on with all our other folks here
uh hi everyone my name is Quincy worthy
and I am the newly hired uh director of
diversity Equity inclusion and justice
for the Concord School District I'm here
with my colleagues from throughout the
state we represent a few school
districts and I am here to just voice my
um concerns and support for repealing
hb61
hi everyone sorry uh Rachel blance at
the pronouns I use her she her hers I'm
the diversity Equity inclusion and
Justice coordinator for Oyster River
Cooperative School District
[Music]
um
upon coming here today this week when I
was talking with my superintendent my
supervisor telling them that I was going
to be here giving testimony and support
of hb61 my superintendent said
well of course that's your job
and I I think it's important to mention
that because I'm honored to represent
one out of the four public school
districts in this state that are
actively putting Ford funds resources in
a position
dedicated to dij work in the state
um but I think what sets me apart in
this position comparatively to my
colleagues is that I work in a small
school district predominantly white
pretty well resourced upon an assortment
of other dominant identities and yet
they also still found it necessary to
have a position like mine in a very
homogeneous School District to create
Equitable experiences for all students
and so thinking about the current hb2
bill and where it stands this not only
hurts our teachers our students but also
the state at Large
we should want our teachers not to live
in fear by doing their jobs and doing
their jobs effectively and correctly
um especially given light of a teacher
shortage right we don't want to lose our
teachers
thinking about we should want our
students of color our lgbtqa plus
students our students with disabilities
our Refugee students our low-income
students
you should want them to see themselves
in their curriculum
we should want to provide a holistic
education to all our students to become
better and more informed citizens of the
world so that they can come here and
give informed opinions we need to really
address this bill
we don't want to go into the discussion
we had with the with the teacher
shortage committee that's a different
area on Arena so let's stick to this
bill and try to wrap it up quickly yes
and so I'm bringing that up because I
would say that hp2 stands in directly to
put our teachers in fear and potentially
lose their jobs from teaching a holistic
and comprehensive education into create
Equitable experiences in the classroom
for our most marginalized students if
not all are students and so that is why
I'm here today to speak in support of
hv61 because this is going to help our
teachers provide more comprehensive
education to our student students not
just all marginalized students but all
our students to become better and more
informed citizens of the world
so our teachers need hb61 our students
need hb61 and so does the State of New
Hampshire thank you
hello everyone my name is Andres Mejia
my pronouns are he him his and I serve
as the Director of diversity Equity
inclusion and justice for sau16 I have
been a resident of New Hampshire for the
13 years I've been working in higher ed
and K-12 in the state
and I'm hearing support for HB 61.
you know and and
hb61 is to support teachers to teach
what they want to teach
um which I agree with uh since hb2 was
put into law I have seen more and more
students getting discriminated against
students being called the n-word and not
being handled appropriately because
Educators do not know if by telling the
student they're calling a black student
to Edward is racist
students from LGBT communities being
called the f word and being told I bet I
can turn you straight
books that represent black people people
of color people from the LG plus
Community Muslims and other historically
marginalized identities taken out of the
classroom because we don't know as
Educators if teaching these perspectives
goes against hb2
because of how it came out and it's fair
the teachers that they can't teach what
they want to teach
um even so far as I I was asked to look
at a book from a classroom about a
Mexican mother teaching her grandchild
how to make empanadas and if we can
teach that in our classrooms
is important that we provide our
students with an education that
represent their identities and
experiences it is important to let
students from historically marginal
identities know that they matter and
that they belong in our education in our
schools and in our state and I believe
hb661 will allow teachers to do that
thank you thank you
hello my name is Tina filovont I am the
chief Equity officer for the Manchester
School District but I come here to you
today in my individual capacity
as a New Hampshire resident a long time
New Hampshire resident 45 years actually
since I was six months old
as an educator as a public school
educator over 15 years as a mother
and as a mother to a daughter who is
educated in our schools K through 12 and
also as a deij diversity Equity
inclusion advocate
like I said I went to school here in New
Hampshire K-12 when I was growing up in
the 80s
I was the only Korean kid
I was the one of five kids of color all
through Elementary School one of maybe a
dozen kids of color all the way through
high school I did not have one single
educator who looked like me or who
understood my experience
K through 18 actually because I did
College here as well
um when I had my daughter years later I
realized the importance of public
education
and one of my mentors at Plymouth State
College back in the day university now
had asked me to stay in New Hampshire to
educate kids and so I did I did I did
um I stayed here to be
the educator I needed
okay
and in the hopes my daughter
would have an educator who would go to
bat for her the way I was about to for
my students
she did not by the way she did not have
a single educator of color
during my time as a public school
teacher I was the only educator of color
not only in my school but in my whole
school district of almost 500 Educators
When Rachel is talking about the fear of
being a teacher under this law that is
real
and imagine what it feels like for the
single teacher of color in a whole
entire District
my daughter went to school here
K-12
when this
hb2 wasn't its
Genesis as HB 544 and I know words
change but the spirit of that law
remains
my daughter came to uh an event like
this it was during the pandemic
um
and gave testimony at the time she was a
senior in high school she just just
turned 18 and she wanted to share her
experience that she didn't feel like she
belonged this whole time
that she didn't feel like teachers
understood her experience that she
didn't feel seen in the curriculum the
way her peers felt seen in the
curriculum
she was sometimes afraid to go to school
because kids would call her a and
a
she gave testimony that day and actually
folks like you said Thank you to the
student who came here who cared enough
to do this work she got it was during
the pandemic so in the chat people
thanked her
um she logged off of Zoom
and immediately A New Hampshire resident
who is watching the testimony
retweeted one of her posts
said that this kid just gave testimony
against HB 544 this student at Concord
High School they named her school
gave testimony against this
called her a few names an adult
within seconds she started receiving
death threats on social media
from throughout the state
from throughout the country
the most visceral one that stands out
for me
was I'd like to see an exit wound leave
your head
the message was very clearly that as a
student and as a kid of color
your voice we don't want to hear it
we're here to shut you up we're going to
threaten you with violence if you show
up to say what you believe
what happened to my daughter
the fear that she had that if HB 544
came to life
that silencing that Chill on speech
what she feared then
now we're living it
in that silence
is real what Andres what Rachel had just
shared with many people in this room it
is real the message is
students especially our students of
color you don't have a voice
you don't belong
what's sad to me is that growing up here
in New Hampshire 80s 90s
I was made to feel invisible
and that is exactly what
hb2 is doing to our kids and our
Educators today
you don't belong here
you don't matter
whatever your intentions were in
creating this bill the net results is
that hb2
insights
what just happened to my daughter
it is inciting
silence that we're here to help stop
so I appreciate your time I thank you
for your tolerance of my emotion
and to be clear I'm here in support of
hb61 so all of our students our
Educators have a chance for a fair and
free education
and to feel like they belong
thank you thank you for your time and
your courage
I'd like to invite now Sally stodd
I think s-t-a-u-d-e
good morning
Sally study Dover New Hampshire
I've been listening carefully to
everyone who has presented this morning
and I can't hear anybody giving an
example of when discrimination
specifically
um
is occurring in the schools with what
the teachers can teach
and
when you look at this as we're somehow
calling the law the current law the
divisive current
Concepts law I'm not quite sure why it's
called that when
um the only things that the teachers are
prohibited from teaching with this law
is what they call CRT I can tell you it
is still being taught because I have all
of the curriculum information from Dover
Schools
uh there is only
inherent racist sexist oppressive
Etc uh terminology that is prohibited
from being taught
in this new proposed bill
providing diverse educational approaches
which is what it proposes to do
does not specifically address a concern
of discrimination if that is the intent
rather it opens a wide door for
implementation of any type of ideology
which is what we are seeing now in the
public schools
disguised as facts
I could name some of the topics from
Dover which I have all the data on so
it's not an imagined idea
allowing for the broad concept of in
quotes in the new proposed proposed law
engaging in any form of instruction
concerning historical or current
experiences of any protected group
that that to me does not inter that
introduces one person's view of an
experience as appropriate
to be applied to all students so if
someone decides that their view is
whatever
that's to be introduced to students as a
factual piece of information for
classroom knowledge
I'd love to know
some examples of real teachers who have
been prosecuted persecuted or prosecuted
for teaching any historical information
as someone else already asked we haven't
heard of any
protections against discrimination are
not joined to how historical or current
experiences are taught in our schools
this bill does not add any new
protection against discrimination when
you compare it to current law and
actually the New Hampshire Constitution
further this bill would only introduce
an unnecessary and intentional level of
confusion to a perfectly clear and
all-inclusive law who is being excluded
from the law as it is currently written
CRT is being taught
in schools
and the divisiveness of that is what we
really ought to be focused on
thank you thank you very much are there
questions from the committee
yes represent woodcock
I think he was the chairman thank you
for taking my question if I understood
part of your uh early speaking uh you
indicated that CRT curriculum is being
taught in the school and you have a copy
of that curriculum
I got the first part of your question
the last part I couldn't hear the the
question was you said in your unclear
you said in your presentation as CRT is
being taught you have a copy of the
curriculum yes I would ask that you
forward a copy that curriculum to the
education committee please I have the
teacher training curriculum the teacher
training
information
from the vendors who who were hired to
train the teachers in it yes okay we
have probably that curriculum through
four no on me but I do have it and I
will certainly be happy to share it
thank you so much thank you Mr chairman
yes
thank you for the questions thank you
very much
I'd like to invite Jessica wheeler
Russell I guess wheeler Russell gotta
get back to work right yeah I know my
last name is everyone trouble okay thank
you so much so um Hello thank you very
much for hearing me today um and thank
you much for all the work that you do my
name is Jessica wheeler Russell I am a
lifetime resident of New Hampshire I was
born and raised in the Upper Valley I
graduated from Lebanon High School in
2005. I currently live in Penacook where
I serve on the Merrimack Valley School
Board while I am here under my own power
and all the views I am about to say I do
not represent the views of the board as
a whole
um I am here in support of hb61 now I
have already sent the committee
um some citations for the claims I'm
going to make I can just summarize and
saying that when we
um allow our teachers to facilitate open
and honest discussions in all aspects of
Education Studies have shown that it
allows students to foster a desire for
civic engagement it improves creativity
and innovation in life and in the
workforce
and it also provides a safer space for
students of all backgrounds
to learn and thrive in an environment
now if you can't tell I spend a lot of
time thinking about education if it's
something that's very near and dear and
important to me
so when HB 55
or the device of Concepts was passed
I have a number of connections to
Educators across the state
and we have heard a lot today about
folks who have been teaching social
studies but one of the other aspects of
this is it's it's affecting other areas
of Education too
I have music teachers who cannot teach
music theory in certain areas because
they're afraid of what might come down
the pipeline they cannot teach musical
history they cannot teach certain genres
of music
there are computer science teachers who
can have open and honest discussions
about the effects of artificial
intelligence a field that is rapidly
growing and a great field to work in I'm
a computer scientist myself
because they are afraid of what might
come down the pipeline
but not only that there are some of my
peers who left the state
who are married and having children and
have flat out told me we were not coming
back because we cannot trust
what is going on and how our children
are being educated here
what I like best about this repealing of
this law of HB 544 is that it is
incredibly vague and while the intention
on paper might not be to gag teachers
that is the effect that it's having
so um thank you very much and um I
appreciate your time today
thank you very much are there questions
from the committee yes representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um you've opened up a new area
um besides just social studies and
Civics and things
um could you flesh out for me maybe what
fear a science person would have let's
talk about artificial intelligence yeah
so um artificial intelligence like I
said is a rapidly growing area but with
that
um I guess the example I would use is
image learning right so you feed images
into an AI and it you might say
something like
um we're going to teach what a bride
looks like right but if what you're
feeding into that is only what we might
see in an American you know traditional
white dress beautiful big Cathedral kind
of situation what you're lacking and
teaching that Ai and what
um what it might look like for
a bride from certain areas of India or
Japan or anything like that and we can't
have the the teachers that are telling
you this say that we can't open this up
because we don't know if saying by the
way you need to be careful about your
ethics in computer science might open
them up to you know you're
discriminating against XYZ person
does that make sense
thank you we're not going to have
follow-up questions
so thank you very much
uh David Scannell skin scanelle yes
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is David scanl I'm a
Bedford resident I teach English
currently at Milford High School I think
I'm the first actual bona fide teacher
who's here today former School Board
member in Manchester a former member of
this house so my opinion about today's
topic is the product of varied
experiences in the classroom in the
community and because I sat where you
sit I appreciate the seriousness with
which you approach this subject
I took a personal day to be here today
because I fear the timing of this
hearing and that's the nature of the
legislative process prevents teachers
the people you really need to hear from
um from being here today I thought it
important to have some skin in the game
and also I believe it's critical that
the record contains specific examples to
the point that the representative is
making of the impact this ill-conceived
law has in the classroom I'm a strong
supporter of hb61 because the statute it
seeks to repeal has sown the seeds of
confusion in the classroom as a result
of its vague and imprecise wording and
Clarity is a critical component of an
effective learning environment
let me share just two examples about the
manner in which this poorly worded
statute has impacted my students
last year one student was interested in
writing his required persuasive research
paper in favor of affirmative action
the language of the statute however
explicitly prohibits teaching that an
individual should be discriminated
against or receive adverse treatment
solely or partly because of age gender
identity sexual orientation
now as we know affirmative action no
matter what one's opinion of the concept
is a constitutionally protected program
of granting historically discriminated
groups advantages others might not be
provided because its members had not
been discriminated against in the past
are we really not allowed to explore
topics the Supreme Court has
consistently endorsed for 60 years
while I ultimately approve the topic I
knew doing so might expose me to certain
risks given the highly partisan and
political nature of the current New
Hampshire Department of Education
similarly another student in another
context expressed a desire to research
the theory of American exceptionalism
which posits its America's place in the
world is a byproduct of the unique
traits of its pioneering and persevering
people
under the divisive Concepts law is a
teacher grading such a paper required to
fail the student if he determines
there's any Merit to American
exceptionalism the statute seems to
suggest no alternative
and those are just two examples of the
ability I'm sorry two examples
um of the ability of the law as
currently constituted to stifle inquiry
and exploration
and finally I want to personally attest
to witnessing countless examples of the
Law's chilling effect I have lost count
of the number of conversations I have
participated in with fellow teachers who
have told me they're avoiding important
lessons or discussions for fear of what
might happen to them thank you very much
for listening I urge you to rate
hb61 as ought to pass thank you very
much questions from the committee not
seeing thank you
uh like to invite Sarah Smith up we have
about
30 to 28 to 30 cards left three minutes
a piece so you can see we're going to go
at least to one o'clock so uh if we can
try to slice this down a little bit I
appreciate it
go ahead
hello my name is Sarah Smith
um and I was a an elementary middle
school a special education for over 25
years
um under this vaguely worded law I could
not truthfully answer questions from
students about their reading material in
elementary school we teach about Martin
Luther King the Holocaust for older
elementary schools students the
Underground Railroad and similar issues
it is totally unclear to me how I would
answer these questions honestly under
this law
how do you explain slavery Jim Crow laws
why Martin Luther King was shot without
talking about the reasons for these laws
anyone who has actually taught children
knows they will ask questions
I have been asked why have why did they
have separate fountains
why did they kill Martin Luther King Jr
there are many conversations we need to
have in today's world they need to be
honest and open
this is why I support this bill
frankly the current law
is a law in search of a problem
I urge you to have this law come to the
floor I would like to see the votes of
all my Representatives
not passed under a budget bill so that
we don't know exactly how people feel
this needs to be out in the open for all
the people here in New Hampshire do not
sweep it under the rug again
any questions
thank you very much
next person is Sarah Robinson
hello my nerves are going to ask I read
directly instead of trying to summarize
I hope that's okay
um thank you Mr chair and the committee
for the opportunity to speak to you
today my name is Sarah Robinson and I'm
the education Justice campaign director
for Granite State progress a multi-issue
advocacy organization working on issues
of immediate state and local concern
in addition to this hat that I'm wearing
today I'm also a parent of Elementary
school-aged children who attend our
local public school and for full
disclosure I am on the Concord School
District School Board but my comments
here today do not speak on behalf of the
Concord School District by now we're all
aware of the effect uh the band Concepts
law has had on our Public School
classrooms what I want to speak about
today is the effect this is having on my
own children and their future as members
of a local and ultimately Global
community
my daughters attend a school that my
family is very proud of my husband and I
have strong relationships with our
daughter's teachers and our girls are
excited to go to school and are valued
in their classrooms the Dark Cloud that
the band Concepts law has cast over our
Public School classrooms will not Escape
our experience despite our strong
involvement in our children's education
will a degree from a New Hampshire
Public School mean the same thing as it
does in other states I know my children
will be prepared for interacting with a
wide range of individuals as they
continue to grow in their individual
paths but what about their peers
perhaps that was the intent of the
original Bill to drive a wedge between
parents and schools to cheapen the
experience for public school students to
continue the effort to degrade the value
of that education to the point that
families Flee for other options
in a recent study from The Brookings
Institute on economic connectedness
which is when people from different
socioeconomic realities build
relationships that is the number one
factor in upward Mobility for families
one of the few places in our society
where the possibility for excuse me
economic connectedness exists is within
the communities built by public
education the continued Sheltering of
the banned Concepts law is a telling act
it lays bare the truth of how little we
honor the people conversations and
relationships that take place there
recommending hb61 is ought to pass is
one step in the direction of repairing
the long-standing harm many and I would
argue all of our students have been
subjected to for decades our children's
Futures depend on a well-rounded
education that is inclusive
compassionate rigorous but most
importantly honest at this present
moment that option is not on the table
our children deserve the freedom to
learn from the mistakes of the past in
order to build a better future together
only those opposed to that goal and
afraid of what honest conversations may
lead to would want to deny our children
the knowledge and Community they need to
learn and grow as thoughtful connected
members of our community please
recommend hb61 to the full legislature
as ought to pass thank you very much
thank you are there any questions from
the committee
thank you very much thank you uh next
person is Misty uh
Crompton uh a mess for anybody on the
committee here feel free if you have to
get up and stretch or get fluids
elsewhere do so come back we we do that
when we're having these committee
hearings so I know you've been sitting
for a long time and you know as a prior
educator myself I know you're supposed
to be letting kids up and down and and
stretch those muscles so same thing
applies to our committee here so welcome
supposed to be red oh yeah there we go
we want you hydrated absolutely I'm also
a teacher so understand
um my name is Misty Crompton I am here
today to lend my support to House Bill
61. I'm a middle school social studies
teacher
um 22 years now I'm a taxpayer and I'm a
mother of two boys who attend public
schools in New Hampshire we live in New
Boston
first I really just have to take a
minute even though I don't have any
extra to respond to the rep at the
beginning from my town who said that you
know teachers you know aren't qualified
to teach anything outside of their
um you know very specific content that
they're going to teach and that doesn't
happen I just wanted to tell kind of a
funny story about that my very first day
of teaching 22 years ago
my very first class was I found out I
was going to be teaching computers and
I'm a social studies trained teacher and
they have Mac computers in New Hampshire
we had PCS where I came from in Vermont
and I it looked like a spaceship to me I
had no idea what it was I didn't know
how to turn it on I had to ask the
students hey do you know how to turn
that on I didn't know what the platform
looked like so anyway
um just my point being we are faced with
things outside of our you know training
and content all the time and it's it's
just what happens and you know teachers
also we frequently handle mandates and
trainings based on you know what we can
do and what we really need to learn to
provide a safe and learning you know
environment for our students and no
matter how complex and difficult we
always somehow work together and we
manage and we face those challenges but
however with the band Concepts
legislation
um it's been really fuzzy right how
we're going to to put this into
education practice and you know unless
it's asking us to ignore the lived
experience of people with our own
communities if we're going to keep our
jobs and I've just gotten to a point in
my career where I really prefer to
listen and and to learn
and you know how are we going to be
doing our best as professionals you know
I've been faced with very odd situations
in my career before but it just seems
like a whole new level if in the middle
of a conversation I have to like get my
lawyers on the phone and be like
is this a situation of inherent racism
you know are they racist because they
watched a movie I don't know it's just
something that we just would dismiss if
it's happening in our communities and
something that we know right from wrong
um
we were hopeful for some kind of clarity
especially within the social studies
department when the guidance came out
for hb2 and it just didn't happen when
that came out it was really just saying
the same language again
um just kind of in a different way and
we didn't get one example in that
document really helping us to understand
how to move forward and the urgency
wasn't there from the state that this
was cutting off oxygen to the teaching
of important aspects of history that
could destroy countless initiatives
before they even came out of somebody's
mind due to the fear of misguided
attacks that we have had and of course
the vague nature of the hb2 language was
that my alarm
that that was the three minutes oh boy
okay I'm like one quarter through what I
was going to say but anyhow I'll just
end with you know please support you
know HB 61 and please trust the teachers
you know I'm I'm vouching for them and
they deserve that thank you
uh next individual is Reverend uh
Reverend Gail Kinney
is she here yes
good morning good morning
um thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is Gail
Kinney I'm a resident of Canaan
um I have and I'm also speaking for the
economic Justice team of the New
Hampshire United Church of Christ also
known as the congregationalist
um the UCC is the largest Protestant
denomination in the state of New
Hampshire
um I've been a public school counselor a
local school board member and School
Board chair and a supervisory Union
School Board chair and now I'm a pastor
um just one thing the original bill that
was tucked into the budget Bill and now
cries out for repeal did not Bubble Up
locally it was part of a national
movement to undermine teachers and
public schools and to foment Fierce
anger towards teachers and schools
particularly in regard to the teaching
about race and gender
and it it was based on this national
movement was a based on wild stories
about Abominations that occurred in the
classroom again particularly in regards
to the teaching about race and gender
and so in New Hampshire when this first
came up there were thousands of people
of Faith who were horrified on by by
this bill which now cries out for repeal
on but at the same time and sadly so
um most people
um believed that the original bill would
go nowhere
um and
because it was grounded not in reality
not in truth not in what was really
happening in the classroom but grounded
on fear grounded on exaggerations on
and it likely if it had not been slipped
into the budget into House Bill 2 it
would not have kind of become law so the
argument for repeal is the reality of
the impact of this law not a word here
or there that's in the legislation but
what it is doing in the state of New
Hampshire and the fact is that this bill
foments fear in the classroom and the
part of teachers and that was part of
its point that was part of the national
movement's Point
um and the fact that this bill
um actually encouraged supporters of the
bill to put on a bounty or a reward for
turning in teachers who purportedly
violate this law that should be of
concern to this legislature a law that
enables that kind of bounty hunting is
not a good law and does not deserve to
be in the statutes of the State of New
Hampshire when I was a a young person
when I was in high school one of the
most popular social studies class this
was a social studies class for primarily
for seniors called problems of democracy
and
this law discourages Stu teachers and
schools from talking about the problems
of democracy
um the oppressions and the division that
existed both in our past and our present
that we can correct if we know about
them if we understand that we learn them
problems of democracy made me a better
student a better person and a better
citizen by learning about that so the
prayer of many many thousands of people
of faith in the state of New Hampshire
is that house bill 61 must be passed and
I thank you for your time and your
attention and your perseverance thank
you any questions from the committee not
seeing any thank you next person is
Betsy Harrington
hi good morning I appreciate the chance
to speak here today my name is Betsy
Harrington I have two sons that attend
Hillsboro during High School in
Hillsboro
I'm a therapist I've worked as a
therapist at the state prison here in
Concord I've also worked as a dcyf
worker doing assessments I have an idea
of what might be appropriate for
children in school especially my own
I have read the constructs of CRT the
themes books and directives my
professional opinion on critical race
theory is one of concern I found many
outright outright lies and some
seriously dangerous instructions let me
quote a few lines from the award-winning
CRT book this book is anti-racist by
Tiffany Jewell
this book teaches the main tenets of CRT
this book was published in 2020 it's
currently advertised to my boys on the
as award-winning reading on their Sora
student Library app it's currently
advertised on the wall at the physical
library with an arrow pointing to it
saying High interest so these books are
in our schools
I kept a picture of that of that book on
the wall in the library in case anyone
actually wants to see it because it's
there right now
it's presented to my children repeatedly
despite the current law that protects
them from being taught this unwanted
curriculum so let me read some lines
that bothered me quote don't be afraid
to disrupt agitate the system and be
abrupt quote get angry stand up to
police brutality attend local protests
and rallies when black and brown folks
are harmed by people the police bring
your family friends teachers and
classmates
I find this to be dangerous advice for
an inexperienced child I don't bring my
kids to protests
protests often have violence even though
it may be unattended listen to the next
lie quote it's our schools being more
segregated today than they were during
the time of legal segregation
that quote isn't true and it agitates
the problem in my opinion
the redistribution of resources is a
theme throughout this book these methods
are based on reparations the ideas are
all presented as truth when they are
opinions not everyone agrees with these
Solutions if kids learn these lies as
truth they will go forward angry and
ready to agitate the system based on
those lies
parents are likely to give their kids
different advice
around combating racism let parents
decide allowing these curriculum's
unwanted and dangerous do not repeal the
bill protecting students from unwanted
curriculum including critical race
Theory I do not support house bill 61.
thank you very much are there questions
from the committee
not see any hands thank you for coming
today
next person is
James Rosner
hello and good morning for the half an
hour it remains morning for us my name
is James Rosner I am state
representative for Concord New Hampshire
um
students do not exist within a vacuum
they observe the realities that many
attempt to Shield them from that many
assume they do not and cannot handle or
comprehend and in many cases they want
to learn when we deny ignore evade or
exclude mentions of the realities that
they experience it does not instill
their trust or attention and to continue
to enact a watchdog program against
teachers does not offer them their very
well deserved deserved support or
loyalty
there is a narrative that around
Prejudice and oppression suggesting that
if we do not talk about these issues
they cease to be issues but this
thinking exposes its own bias because it
relies on the exclusion of the voices
warning us otherwise a colorblind and
gender-blind world is not a possibility
today nor do I think or believe it is
characteristic of what we should be
striving for
is not until we listen to those affected
and learn about the curtain incantations
of oppressive violence that we can put
it to an end having conversations around
racism sexism and other forms of
Oppression that are proactive and
relevant has become very difficult under
this bill like we have heard it is also
emboldened Bad actors adult and student
alike to take the opportunity to
discriminate against minorities
acknowledging the existence of racism
and teaching our students on historical
and current day racism is not itself a
form of racism it is a form of Education
in this imperative piece of full
education that our students have a right
to receive and with that considered I
urge you to support the passing of hb61
thank you thank you very much are there
questions
thank you very much
if there are any Representatives if you
usually you should put in the bottom of
your your form here representing and you
put your your county and your your
number down if you don't do it we don't
recognize it so it's okay I apologize
okay next person is Abigail Kincaid
welcome thank you good morning well
actually I guess it's approaching
afternoon now
um my name is ABIA Kincaid and I am a
senior at Bedford High School in the
town of Bedford I actually am skipping
school today to be here to testify in
support of house bill 61. barring
Educators from allowing the space to
discuss essential topics such as race
gender and sexuality is a grave
disservice and failure to New Hampshire
students
these efforts do not protect students as
proponents of these policies claim
they instead endanger them to the risk
of ignorance and intolerance the
classroom must remain a space that
Fosters challenging conversations and
personal growth through the expansion of
our understanding of the world House
Bill 61 protects diversity equity and
inclusion conversations from State
censorship which is something very near
and dear to my heart
in 2020-2021 I served on the diversity
committee at Bedford High School as one
of the student Representatives
we created a presentation of real
stories from students at Bedford to
present to our community
that have experienced racism and
homophobia
that that presentation was followed by a
conversation about what to do about it
and how people felt
people have to be okay being
uncomfortable these conversations are
uncomfortable
and that is something that without that
we do we cannot grow and change
the work of this committee was creating
real change at Bedford unfortunately
though we were curbed by the passing of
HB 544 or the device of conscious ban
in addition to that committee I am the
President of the diversity equity and
inclusion Club at Bedford High School
the goal of our club is to create a
space for students to have discussions
about hard topics and work to create a
school that centers diversity through
education being president of this club
in a time where these conversations
cannot be had in the classroom
has been very eye-opening students have
come to me to express grave confusion on
why their story that they relate to in
history is being brushed over so quickly
or why their identity is seemingly being
erased from conversations this is not
about political parties it's about
building community and keeping the
school
a safe place where students feel seen
and heard
I also canvassed this summer in my
community against the device of
conscious ban and the outrage was clear
people were shocked that New Hampshire
would create a ban like the divisive
conscious ban in our schools history
matters because it repeats itself and if
we're not having the uncomfortable
conversations about race gender
sexuality religion how can we honestly
say we won't repeat history again
how can we sit here in contempt of the
cries from students and Educators to
change things in our schools this is not
about winning or losing it's about doing
right by the Youth of New Hampshire and
that is why I urge the committee to vote
ought to pass on hb61 thank you for your
time and I'll take any questions
thank you very much are there and it's
always encouraging to see students
coming down and and participating in the
in the process that we have here I
appreciate that any questions from the
committee yes representative leckis
thank you for coming thank you um have
you read the the what ended up going
into law
yes I have read um HB 544 and hb61 both
very thoroughly and multiple times but
HP 544 wasn't what into I'm talking
about what actually went into law what
was in sb2 yes yes okay good
um since you
good question
um
since you
have read that I'm hoping you can
explain to me how what the words in that
law say
um keep you from doing the awesome
things that you've been doing
so
I think everyone has answered your
question already has said it very
adequately but I will add that from my
own personal experience as a student who
is very Humanity centered um meaning I
take classes like for example U.S
government world history two I'm taking
environmental science this year I know
that like from the years that I was in
high school before this Bill had passed
those conversations were happening up
like oh let's talk about
um the messaging behind this book or
like for example right now we're talking
about
um the Red Scare and like why did the
Red Scare happen and conversations like
that are happening but now for example
in my AP Gov class if a student comes up
and says oh well can we talk about
why I think this problem this Paul this
certain policy for example is
problematic the teacher has to say I'm
sorry but we actually can't talk about
that we can't have that discussion
because that discussion
is divisive and that's what that's what
that bill does is it doesn't want us to
talk about things are that are divisive
so I think the vagueness of the bill is
what creates this like fear-mongering
and I think
um
part of the reason why you're I feel
like having such a hard time
um understanding why it's happening is
because teachers don't even know why
because teachers are sitting here
confused because the bill isn't clear
and that's why we need to repeal it and
support HP 61. thank you very much
further questions thank you uh Aubry
Friedman
foreign
committee members Aubry Friedman a
private citizen and taxpayer and I'll
submit a a summary of my bullet points
here
um I speak in opposition to HB 61.
um the current law
it protects students from teachers who
push their Politics on their students so
I think it's reasonable
the law the way it is that you leave
your politics out of the classroom and
just teach the subjects period and the
only problem with the current law was it
was watered down if a teacher is
promoting and advocating racism or
sexism they should be fired period
and so that's the only problem with the
law is a little bit uh the parents have
to find recourse now a lot has been
discussed about
uh freedom of expression here
intellectual Freedom uh every employer
has the right to have certain rules uh
for your employees to have to follow and
I don't think it's unreasonable that
teachers cannot bring their politics
into the classroom okay now the big
issue here that was discussed a lot
today
is
every the teachers are afraid to discuss
here's from the current law section two
RSA 19340 quote nothing in this section
shall be construed construed to prohibit
discussing discussing as part of a
larger course of academic instruction
the historical existence of ideas and
subject identified in this section again
it's discussion you can discuss uh
pass that slavery or KKK or redlining or
reparations or 1619 projects you can
discuss it there should be no reason
that teachers should be afraid to
discuss it you just cannot Advocate or
indoctrinate I think it's pretty clear
so if teachers are not doing anything
wrong
there should be nothing again just
discussing and I'd say rather than
pushing victimhood and bringing personal
politics into the classroom they should
be concentrating on the basic things
like reading arithmetic and writing and
get back to the core stuff and not
worrying about victimhood and stuff like
that if you look at the proficiency
scores they're unbelievable they're 40s
30s even 20 percent ranges so that
really should be the focus and lastly I
say if teachers are that worried about
it actually we should have cameras
recording in every government classroom
pointing at the teachers so that parents
know what's being taught since they
don't really allow parents in the
classrooms that much anymore and then
also teachers could feel protected too
that they didn't do anything or say
anything that was their personal
politics and that's it thank you thank
you very much are there questions from
the committee
yes representative Woodcock thank you Mr
chairman uh good afternoon and thank you
for taking my question would you think
it would be fair then for or allowable
under your interpretation for a teacher
to create a debate on the existence or
non-existence of racism in the classroom
let that go back and forth oh see that a
debate would be fine a debate is good
actually it would be that the students
that are debating uh the teachers they
would just be mediating the discussion
so that would be perfectly good that's
encouraged and that should be totally
allowable under the current law debate
is good
well mediated you know they're just you
know a debate is mediated
thank you
no no further questions thank you uh I'd
like to invite up Kate West
hi thank you for the opportunity to
speak to you today my name is Kate West
I have a 10 year old in the Concord
School District
um and one of the things that I keep
hearing is how does this law prevent
honest discourse in the classroom uh to
me this seems very clearly like a we can
talk about the cause but not the effect
so I think that when you say in this law
you can't teach that somebody is
inherently Superior based on their
identity
um it's more so a way to deny the
reality of the structures in our society
and how they do uphold superiority right
if you say women and men are equal
that's wonderful we would love that but
there is a wage Gap and not addressing
that
is only beneficial
to one group of people and so it seems
to me that the purpose of this law and
we've heard that the impact of this law
is to wish away the inequities in our
society by teaching children that they
don't exist
um which is ineffective
there's work to be done to create a
society where you are not discriminated
against based on your ability your
gender your race your religion
Etc this law
completely ignores that work that needs
to be done and teaches children that
it's over
uh
I think honestly one other aspect that I
would point out is to say
when it comes to discussions of race
I have found as someone that
wants to work to be anti-racist
that two very big indicators that
something is racist is one when people
that are black or indigenous Hispanic
Asian American Etc come to a body like
this and tell you it's racist
that's a pretty easy indicator that it
is secondly when self-identified white
supremacist groups support and advocate
for something again
that's a pretty clear indicator that
it's upholding racism
thank you thank you very much are there
questions from the committee
thank you
I just had several
Representatives show up I'll let them
know that I'm going to have the folks
have been sitting here testify first
they will get those reps later
at the end of it next person is Ruby
Carr
good afternoon my name is Ruby Carr I
use they them pronouns and I'm
testifying in support of hb61
I've lived in New Hampshire for my
entire life I went to co-brown for high
school and I'm currently a student at
UNH and a very important part of my life
is my LGBT identity I've noticed not a
lot of people have spoken about that
aspect of this bill today but I was
incredibly lucky to have a very
supportive environment in which to
discover who I am in high school and
then again in college
um and I would not have been able to
figure out my gender and sexuality or to
accept either if it weren't for groups
like my high school is GSA and also very
supportive teachers
uh particularly those who identified in
the same way as me who I got to see
living their lives openly
um additionally I want to be a teacher
myself someday but the divisive concept
span that's currently in place uh
jeopardizes all of this how can teachers
be supportive and open about their
identities if they're constantly in fear
of the potential repercussions just for
existing
as part of a class last year I got to
Shadow a middle school teacher in
Stratham for a semester and when
introducing myself to the students I was
afraid to go by my correct pronouns
which is just who I am and for fear that
I would get the school or the teacher I
was shadowing in trouble kids need to
see representation of people living
openly and happily with their shared
identities in order to accept themselves
and their their best way to learn this
is through teachers
um I wish I had seen representation
earlier in my life so that I would have
been able to explore my identity and
live openly sooner
um so this bill would allow teachers and
students both to feel safe and to be
open again in school and thank you and
please vote in support of hb61 thank you
very much
I have questions from the committee
not seeing any hands thank you
next individual is Lynn close
hello and thank you for having this
important hearing my name is Lynn Clues
I live in Warner New Hampshire
I'm in favor of house bill 61.
I believe we become better when we learn
honest history the race relations of
this country today are hugely influenced
by the histories of race relations in
this country when we learn about the
past in honest detail we can devise
excuse me A Better Way Forward today
I studied history in college I learned
so much that opened my eyes
then I became a high school
history teacher in New Hampshire and a
trainer
I always like to ask people to think
about what they're reading or hearing is
it rhetoric
is it reality what's the balance
I enjoy helping people open their eyes
to facts in hopes of the increasingly
informed and thoughtful residents of New
Hampshire building authentic race
relations and solutions to the many
problems of today's society
there was a time when many people said
there was no climate change today cities
and countries worldwide are working to
build protections against rising sea
levels and other problems due to the
reality of climate change
planning how to reduce carbon Footprints
this couldn't happen if leaders were
still denying the existence of climate
change like climate change in race
relations acknowledgment is crucial our
nation's promise of fairness and
opportunity for all people cannot be met
without first acknowledging there has
been and continues to be undeserved
discrimination against black native and
other community members of color
what if we teach the unfairnesses and a
child feels guilty
if someone feels guilty
they may move forward themselves or with
the help of the people around them their
parents and Educators with more learning
about how to be part of the solutions to
build fairness and opportunity
suppressing training and denial about
difficult topics only breeds more denial
let us move forward refuse to deny
oppressive historic periods encourage
acknowledgment of difficult race
relations so that this all may serve to
move our society toward racial fairness
and authentic cross-race relations HP 61
is a big step in the right direction
thank you thank you are there any
questions for the presenter
is that written testimony right there
great thank you
uh next person's uh Ronnie Harding
finally
yeah we're getting there
um as you can see
um based on comments that have been said
today and had to um kind of amend what I
wanted to say and I am going to read
from it so that hopefully I won't ramble
around like people and say a lot of
crazy
personal antidotes my background is yes
my name is Ronnie Harding I live in
Wolfeboro I'm a recently retired teacher
I have a BS degree in curriculum and
instruction a master's degree in
education leadership and supervision I'm
also a certified reading specialist and
an ESL or Esau specialist I taught for
36 years and my last 15 years most
recently were in a title one
Multicultural school it was 80 percent
Black and Hispanic
I am totally against
hb61 which probably shocks you since I'm
a teacher
I feel like this is an attempt to
promote the use of divisive
discriminatory Concepts lessons in
terminology in New Hampshire classrooms
I believe that no child no student no
human being should be instructed or
treated as if they are superior inferior
privileged or oppressed because of their
race religion ethnicity or gender
there's absolutely no benefit in doing
this it's very much violation of the
wise old admonition to not judge a book
by its cover and there is no research
that says the CRT type education is a
best practice
Educators in particular should be the
ultimate role models for demonstrating
positivity and acknowledging every
student's uniqueness this requires not
labeling students or making any
judgments or assumptions in the
classroom which are discriminatory a
good teacher is able to treat every
person as a unique individual their
focus should be on learning and academic
success
RSA 193.40 which some of you are trying
to repeal grants the assurance that
every student can be treated as the
special unique human that they are and
not as a created identity group contrary
to the misinformation claim today I
could find nothing in this RSA that
prohibited the teaching of any
historical facts or events that may
involve people of different races or
cultures it does however prevent
prohibit making unwarranted assumptions
about students and using those
assumptions to discriminate in a school
setting
um this seems to bother some of the
teachers here and I find that very sad
I feel that the bill is not confusing in
fact it's quite specific
I feel that Educators should be similar
to doctors Do no harm dividing labeling
and making assumptions about students is
inherently harmful
and for those of you that are really
intent upon dwelling in the past one of
my favorite quotes is that there's a
reason our windshield before us is so
large and the rearview mirror is so
small I ask that you not pass hb61 and I
feel that it's based upon nothing but
false allegations thank you
thank you are there any questions of the
presenter
not see any thank you very much
uh next card is
it's Jay Buffon
and I apologize uh is j-o-u-r
[Music]
yes
j-o-u-r-n-e-e Journey okay thank you yes
thank you so much for having me thank
you for your time I will try to be
concise
it's not my strong point so I ask for
your forgiveness ahead
um yes my name is Journey Lafond I am a
therapist I am a resident of Concord New
Hampshire uh for several years I've had
the pleasure of serving this community
especially as family and its youth both
through the community mental health
system and through Private Practice
um to get into it there appears to be
fear among New Hampshire residents and
Americans in general
that so-called divisive Concepts such as
critical race Theory or the discussion
of oppressive symptoms are merely
attempts to either admonish or divide
based on race or their own status as
patriotic Americans
the issue that we appear to be having is
that
some Americans are unable to separate
themselves their identities as
individuals from that of American social
institutions
this group believes themselves to be the
system and are therefore perpetuating
the very issues which are so worth
discussing especially in the classroom
there are others who believe that
America is now an equitable democracy
when in fact it remains exceedingly
unfair and unequitable to many
this fact then becomes normative without
the discussion to the point I fear of
going completely unrecognized
to be frank CRT does not suggest that
white people today are directly
responsible for America's problematic
past however it does highlight a moral
responsibility to confront racism and to
that end sexism queer phobia ableism and
discrimination in general
any Apollo any policy attempting to
suffocate these conversations stands in
the way of an equitable democracy for us
and for our children
and to address the question that has
continued to come up today
laws can be read one way and interpreted
another way and it's the ambiguity I
fear that presents the danger so to be
extremely clear I am in support of hb61
and I thank you for your time
thank you very much are there any
questions from the committee
not seeing thank you
uh Jody Newell
welcome
hello okay here we go I was gonna say
I'm loud not that loud
um I am here as a state representative
but also as a mom a mom who homeschooled
my two boys for a year in elementary
school and if my curriculum was
scrutinized I'm not really sure how
everyone would feel about it
um but I believe that teaching my
children the truth an accurate account
of our country's Origins starting with
the indigenous people whose land was
ravaged and whose culture was destroyed
so that's what I did
my ancestors
Mayflower people
took part in this
while stating that does not evoke a
sense of Pride it certainly doesn't make
me feel ashamed
with limited time I'm just going to
shorten it up I'm going to respond to
the question I've heard reported I've
heard repeated here today
I keep hearing essentially that this
bill's language is innocuous that there
is no harm and that it seeks to create a
colorblind Society
it is indeed an unnecessary Bill and it
would seem an unpopular one as evidenced
by the fact that it was added into the
budget rather than standing on its own
Merit
the real question is what was the point
of it
what was the point of passing an
unnecessary and unpopular bill and we
can see that in its impact
fortunately we have not seen cases yet
and to be fair we really wouldn't
because there wasn't a problem with this
in the first place
but we have seen extreme scrutiny and
unrest in school board meetings around
curriculum attacks on our teachers
school board members and public servants
in the name of so-called divisive
Concepts we have seen the chill the
removal of books that many in my
generation hold dear
we've heard teachers Express deep
concern in fear in approaching topics
which are essential to a child's
comprehensive understanding of our
history and of human nature
in my district I see the manifestation
of unrestrained hate in our schools
our children have been through a lot in
their manifestation
is coming out
ignorance of racism and of homophobia
in the name of reducing division
that this bill purports of relieving
guilt of creating a colorblind Utopia
this bill in fact invites contention
Erasure and Division
I urge you to support hb61 thank you
thank you very much are there any
questions from the committee
I'll see you thank you
next person is
representative I didn't realize that
you're in this bundle here represent
Nick Jermaine
from Keen
thank you Mr chairman thank you to
members of the committee uh special
thanks to members of the public who are
here to testify today and also to uh the
scores of teachers who are working hard
with our children in classrooms right
now who I know filled out uh online
testimony that the committee will have
the opportunity uh to see I am a
representative from Keene I am also a
professional historian an academic
historian and I want to address uh
specifically the question that some of
the community members have raised about
what it is about the current law that
inhibits or prohibits teachers from
being able to do their jobs
much of the drama around how U.S history
is taught results from a
misunderstanding about the nature of
systemic racism and what that term
systemic racism means
we know for example that the origins of
policing in the American South grew out
in slave Patrols in the 19th century we
know that the organization the creation
and organization of police forces in
Northern cities in the United States was
a direct response to the great migration
of black Americans out of the South
fleeing lynching in the 1920s and the
1930s we also know that after World War
II
uh the Veterans Administration engaged
in inequitable distribution of resources
around home loans for veterans which
meant that black veterans did not
receive the resources that white
veterans did that leads over generations
to a major difference in terms of the
accumulation of wealth between the
families of those white veterans and
black veterans all of whom violently
served our country
we also know that the penal system in
the south
which was then exported to much the rest
of the country uh was a large part of an
effort to effectively re-enslaved free
people through the mass incarceration of
blacks on farms where they were forced
into labor to to benefit uh the states
and private employers
we know that redlining which was
referred to earlier was a common
practice which again prevented uh black
families in the United States from
buying homes and accumulating the wealth
uh that whites were able to uh
accumulate and we all know of course
that all of our homes rest on land that
was stolen from native peoples our
financial security as homeowners in this
state rests on the fact this land was
taken from the people who rightfully
owned it in the first place now to say
that we all as white Americans benefit
from those systems that were designed to
perpetuate racial inequality is not the
same as saying that white people are
inherently racist but there were those
who will argue based upon the vague
language of this law that that's exactly
what it does if a student goes home to a
parent or a parent feels that teaching
about these systemic inequalities in our
system is effectively saying that white
people are guilty and it opens teachers
up to this response representative thank
you I just went very quickly I'm a
German historian and I cannot imagine
for the life of me that a bill like this
would ever be introduced in Germany
today thank you very much for your
testimony
um we have about 45 minutes left of
bills here so some of those that are on
the committee here we have another bill
starting up in about that time too so we
we ought to take some turns here and
going out and getting some lunch and
taking a break so as we've done
previously those that would like to you
know get up and go have something before
we start up at one o'clock again and I
also have Megan Tuttle come up next here
because you may be also testifying at
one o'clock so why don't you come
forward and we'll we'll keep moving on
so don't be bashful if you want to go
out and take a little break for lunch
a lot of members of the committee I will
keep this short um a substantially
shortened an alternative written
testimony to help the process today
for the record my name is Megan Tuttle
I'm president of Nea New Hampshire
representing
um about 17 000 Educators across the
state of New Hampshire I'm also a mom of
three boys and uh
18-year veteran social studies teacher
for more than 168 years it's been a New
Hampshire's mission to advocate for the
children and the Public School Employees
of New Hampshire we're committed to
improving student achievement in New
Hampshire in the public schools
providing learning opportunities for
teachers and students and ensuring that
all students are ready to succeed I'm
here today to testify strongly in favor
of House Bill 61 a bill that would
repeal the ban Concepts law passed in
2021 replace it with language that
protects our students freedom to learn
and Educators ability to give them an
education that helps prepare them to
succeed since the proposal and Inception
of the ban Concepts law that was
inserted into house bill 2. and Yea New
Hampshire is held that the Law's
vagueness would have a chilling effect
on Educators throughout the state after
seeing the law in action over the past
year and a half our members our students
and parents know that this is true
there's a lot that's Crossing
teachers want to provide our children
with the best education they can but the
band concept Act is created an
environment that limits the context in
which kids can learn about history and
what books they can read we need to be
trusting Educators to ensure that our
kids get the best education possible I'm
just going to stop for a minute and Echo
what has been said previously by
teachers by public by parents Etc that
are in support of House Bill 61 and not
go over the same thing teachers are
trained inexperienced in education
that's what they go to school for their
professionals their professional
Educators and they have a duty to set up
their students to be successful
contributors to society Educators should
have the freedom to teach honest
complete facts about history and events
like slavery and civil rights without
being censored and having their licenses
and their livelihoods put at risk by
vague law the chilling effect that keeps
being talked about here today is that
educators are fearful that they will
have their license taken away because of
an interpretation that could be made by
somebody in their class House Bill 61
restores the ability to provide diverse
educational approaches to instruction
and curriculum tailored to meet students
needs our students deserve the freedom
to learn they deserve to be part of an
education that helps them learn from the
mistakes of the past so they're better
prepared to succeed in the future
to inhibit New Hampshire's Educators
from engaging in the kinds of
discussions that help teach and
challenge students to use this knowledge
to form their own opinions is a
disservice to them to the state of New
Hampshire and to our country I'm past
behalf of Nea New Hampshire and its
membership I respectfully ask that you
find House Bill 61 otipass thank you
thank you very much are there any
questions for Miss Tuttle yes rappers
like us
call this the band Concepts law so I'm
wondering if you could
enlighten me as to what the band
concepts are there's we call it band
Concepts divisive Concepts House Bill
too there's many different names that's
one that we took last year from things
we were hearing from others but it's the
it's the there's nothing in the law so
specifically cannot teach something
right we've that's been discussed but
it's the effect of what could be
happening to an educator and that's been
provided I mean the woman sitting next
to me had an amazing answer to the
question so I don't want to say it any
different but it's that effect that your
license could be taken away because of
an interpretation or something that
could be happening that that's a very
real threat and a very real feeling to
the Educators have some have said
earlier earlier today in this room and
what I've been hearing from my members
for the past year thank you
thank you very much any further
questions thank you very much I'd like
to invite up John uh Jonathan Weinberg
not here
okay
uh James McKim
welcome
thank you Mr chair and esteemed members
of the education committee my name is
James McKim
I live in Goffstown New Hampshire
I am a managing partner for a Consulting
practice called organizational ignition
it's one of my hats I also serve as the
president of the Manchester branch of
the NAACP
it's in my personal capacity that I'm
here today though
uh and would like to just speak to a few
points about this bill I rise in support
of hb61
and I agree with the general approach of
the right to freedom from Discrimination
Act
children should be taught about the true
history
and nature of the protected classes
that are mentioned in
that act
and that act does allow for and
encourage teaching of that true history
however
that act fails to consider
that racism
sexism ageism
are actually inherent in our legislation
and in our society
as evidenced by the systemic
discrimination
built into our institutions
and systems
because of our personal biases
and the biases that are baked into
policies and procedures of our
institutions
reading from the act itself
section 354 a31 Section 3
will allow white males to say that
they've been adversely cheated
if someone from a protected class gets a
job over them
or gets into a school over them
even if all other skills are equal
section four
ignores the fact that there are
inequalities in the status of different
groups
such that they create a society
where people have equal opportunity
they must be treated equitably and
there's a difference between equal
treatment and Equitable treatment it's a
nuanced
difference but equal treatment is where
we give everybody the same thing as if
they have the same needs
Equitable treatment is where we give
people what they need because we
recognize they are not equal
the impact and the impact has been
spoken about by many people
and the impact of from a teacher's
perspective has been spoken about by
many people
I wonder though if you have heard the
impact from an individual high school
student
who had a death threat written on a
school wall in a school in New Hampshire
I'm not going to mention
the administration
froze
they did not take action and they're
still struggling to figure out what
action they can take
to make this student safe
can you please wrap it up quickly
absolutely three minutes so
with that example of the of the impact
of this law I urge you to support HP 61.
thank you very much questions from the
committee
not seeing any thank you for you're good
next person is uh
Michael Pelletier
not here
uh Jason Bonilla
Bonilla okay thank you yeah you're
welcome uh so uh good afternoon
everybody
all right so here we go so I am a proud
Salvadorian and I come from a family of
immigrants
um who came to this country by foot and
I'm also a school board member in
Manchester New Hampshire
so see I've never been to these chambers
before and I look at this committee and
it's wild that none of y'all look like
me
people say that don't bring your
politics into the classroom but at the
end of the day my own my very own
identity is political
this testimony is in favor of House Bill
61 and I'm here representing myself
I look at the divisive kinds of spell
and it's as though the creation of the
bill centers white guilt our students or
Future Leaders deserve the right to know
the real history
why are we running away from having
critical conversations on Race gender
and sexual orientation
like why are we moving backwards the
demographics in New Hampshire as we all
see are slowly changing
and it's critical for us to have these
conversations as a community and as a
family
over the past couple years the divisive
concept bill has disproportionately
impacted are you from the bipod
community
it's as though we are telling them that
their voices don't matter like Tina
mentioned
I heard someone saying that legislator
that the legislator is here to protect
us but I'm going to be real with y'all
it's very hard for me to see that when I
when they're barely individuals that
look like me being represented
we should not be censoring our schools
or teachers from having conversations on
race
gender and sexual orientation
like what are we doing this is 2023 and
students deserve the representation of
real history thank you
thank you very much are there any
questions
thank you for coming today
I'd like to have come forward Deborah
Howes
good afternoon
good afternoon yes thank you is it good
afternoon already
um I could pull out my phone and check
the time but I believe it is just
afternoon okay thank you to your live
and members of the education committee I
appreciate the chance to address you
today my name is Deborah house I am
president of the American Federation of
teachers New Hampshire we have 4 000
members mostly in K-12 public education
also University faculty and public
employees and I am here today to speak
overwhelmingly in favor of HB 61
repealing these so-called divisive
Concepts band
um the divisive Concepts law is uh it's
a bad law it's unfair to students who
deserve to be learning honest history
and not censored history they deserve a
full and robust public education
um they deserve to be reading a wide
variety of literature and they don't
deserve to have that censored
it is intimidated imperative teachers
who have an obligation to teach honestly
and and fully and without reservation
looking over their shoulder all the time
it should never have been passed and it
should be repealed and I'm not going to
read all of my testimony but I'm going
to try and illustrate some of the impact
of this law because I've heard the
question asked again and again you know
how does the law that was passed have
this impact that you're talking about
well the law that was passed
gave
many the impression
that it is now illegal
to talk about racism sexism
and discrimination in Public School
classrooms in New Hampshire and even
though we will hear arguments that
that's nowhere in the text of the law
that is the impression out there and
some feel emboldened
to demand
investigations and punishments of
teachers
who try and have
discussions that should rightfully be
part of their curriculums because they
are part of this standards that we're
supposed to teach
in their classrooms I'm going to give
you a few examples since the passage of
the song called divisive Concepts law
some Middle School teachers are now
questioning whether they can teach To
Kill a Mockingbird
that is a classic of American literature
but it's got some very obvious scene
themes of racism in it
now you
clearly going to be okay teaching the
book but what about if a student
has a problem with the discussion around
it or what if a student goes home and
reports something to a parent and that
report gets Tangled Up third hand and
third hand reports are enough to start
an investigation
a dedicated middle school art teacher
works every semester to build a
community in her classroom
to get to know her students part of what
she does is
ask them what should I call you
someone took offense of that and thought
that was an impermissible breach of this
device of Concepts law
that that was bringing her politics into
the classroom
by trying to show respect to students
and asking what they want to be called
demanded an investigation
including putting pressure on the Local
District by going directly to the
commissioner of Education
that teacher was not found I'm sorry
that teacher was not found in any breach
of the law but because of the pressure
in The Witch Hunt atmosphere that
teacher has left public education and my
third example AP History teacher
in her final review with her students
before the AP test last spring got that
call from the office
someone heard you were teaching
something that was in violation of this
law
so her review with her students before
the AP test this is important for high
school students
was interrupted
to answer an allegation that she taught
something that was improvisible she's
teaching the approved curriculum meeting
the the estate standards for AP History
but apparently we can't do that because
of the perception that we cannot address
reconstruction other things that deal
with racism yes so in conclusion
New Hampshire students need and New
Hampshire parents want us to teach
honestly they want us to do our jobs
thoroughly they want a robust public
education I urge you to repeal the
so-called divisive Concepts law and pass
HP 61. thank you
and I do have this
any questions from the committee I'll
see you thank you the next person is
Walter
Kissel
see here
Michelle Bessie
from the nhsaa New Hampshire school
administrator Association anybody here
yes
foreign
thanks for the opportunity to speak here
today my name is Dr Sydney Leggett I'm
currently serving as the superintendent
of schools for Grantham Plainfield and
Cornish school districts in the Upper
Valley region
all combined these three districts
represent approximately 1 000 students
and their families in New Hampshire
I'm addressing you today as the chair of
the New Hampshire school administrators
Association Equity committee
as an educator and instructional leader
I'm asking you to support the passage of
hb61 to repeal the divisive Concepts law
this law is contrary to what we want our
schools communities and our state to be
one purpose of school is to prepare
students for college and work as New
Hampshire seeks to attract businesses
it's crucial that the state presents
itself as a place open to diversity a
place where businesses and the families
connected to them feel they belong and
that they're included
repealing the divisive Concepts law
sends a clear message that New Hampshire
is a good place to be and that when
businesses move here workers will feel
at home and their families can send
their kids to schools where everyone
belongs
another purpose of school an essential
one is modeling our democracy
one of the nhsaa resolutions States the
following
nhsaa opposes legislation that would
restrict freedom of intellectual inquiry
in the classroom and hsaa believes that
patriotism Freedom sound traditional
family values and individual ethics are
strengthened not weakened through
rigorous analysis and thoughtful inquiry
our schools offer a safe space where
students will learn to have respectful
open and thoughtful conversations about
important issues
ideally this carries through to their
adult lives the divisive Concepts law
makes teachers feel unclear about
facilitating these conversations and
many teachers now feel afraid to do this
deep and meaningful work within their
classrooms this is the chilling effect
you've already heard about today and all
that this will accomplish the only real
effect is diminishing our students
future and our Stu our citizens future
of their ability to think reason Express
themselves and work collaboratively
collaboratively with others
I work in small rural schools and I have
seen firsthand the way that communities
can disagree with great thought and
respect for one another and still move
forward with decisions the way it's
supposed to be
our schools lay the groundwork for all
of that
teachers love it when students think
especially for themselves and when they
can back those thoughts up with data and
clear expression throughout my 25 years
of experience in public schools I have
yet to see any teacher use the classroom
to make students think in a particular
certain way
rescinding the divisive Concepts laws
shows your faith in our state's
outstanding schools and the dedicated
professional Educators who work with all
of our children by voting in favor of
hb61 you're voting and your belief in
New Hampshire public education
I appreciate the time you've taken to
listen for your service I'd be happy to
answer any questions thank you very much
any questions from the committee
I see any thank you and have a good
afternoon thank you you're welcome
Martin Tove
uh
six members of the committee
um kid I think is afternoon now but I
won't be long
um I want to preface by quoting uh from
my Memoir
um from Jane Connolly who was my high
school principal
um I went up
one of Jane's speeches he quoted he says
he said this he says pay attention uh be
excellent say hello to everyone you see
have courage think before you speak
embrace
Embrace gratitude don't be afraid to
tell someone that you love them and my
favorite tell the truth
and family comes first
I'll I
um I work with uh at I work at the
granite state organizing project and I
work with clergies and I also organize
within the African Community as well
and uh I want to share my story I came
here in 2003 I'm from Ivory Coast and uh
while uh my first my um
when I I was in sixth grade I remember a
peculiar experience where I was at Rite
Aid
um run this runlit on on my way
um to write it when I was at Rite Aid
the I went in the store and the cashier
started following me around and
and supposing that perhaps I was up to
no good and that I was gonna maybe grab
a drink or a candy and put it in my
pocket and walk out but uh unbeknowing
to that cashier there was a another a
young gentleman in in the store
after she had walked by him
uh him and I were in the same aisle then
he stashed a couple of gums and some
candy in his pants and walked out and I
went and paid for my um for my sweets
and um
I I had no one in in
um
in in my sixth grade classroom to talk
about that experience with and the only
person that I felt comfortable enough
was my fifth grade teacher
um Mr G
and at the time
um him and I I would constantly go over
um from runland across to Conan which I
I believe now is um either Abbott
Downing
um I would go over and we would talk
about
um
what
it is like living in in Two Worlds or
what it's like experiencing a racism
because as a young man I didn't know
what it was and
um and quite frankly I was blind to it
until we started having these
conversations
um
now that you know I'm out of college and
I've experienced life a little more
um I still keep in contact with my fifth
grade teacher
um
artifact we talked constantly and also
my second grade teacher and as well as
um
uh
the crtc
um uh uh
um vice president who I consider my
mentor
we talk about
the struggles that our teachers are
going through right now concerning
this specific bill
which is the bill that unlimits folks
from having conversation in the
classroom about the hard things that
they might not be able to talk about
outside of the classroom because maybe
Mom and Dad might not be experienced
around the co uh the conversation as
whereas in the classroom setting there's
that structure where they are able to
have those conversations I recently can
I try to wrap it up I'll wrap it up
right now I recently heard
um
uh that teachers are afraid to even uh
talk about Martin Luther King's day
which is a holiday here in New Hampshire
and if that's if that is what this uh
bill is
is you know perpetuating then you know
it has to be scrapped and so that's why
I'm here today to testify and share my
story with you that I'm in support of
hb61 thank you God bless you
thank thank you very much any questions
from the committee for no thank you uh
Frank
and after Frank we have five cards left
Mr chairman members of the committee
thank you so much for the opportunity to
testify my name is Frankie Knack I'm the
policy director with the ACLU of New
Hampshire and we are here in strong
support of HB 61. you've already heard
from multiple people about how the real
world implications of how the current
law impacts and restricts the ability of
teachers to give our students a full
picture of American History both the
good and the bad I want to really focus
on hopefully clarifying some of the
questions that have been raised about
you know what is in this current
language that's so problematic and it's
really you know this has been somewhat
touch to bond but I want to drill into
it a little bit and it's really two
aspects it's the vagueness and it's the
penalties
right now there's
um it's very unclear in terms of what
what uh the divisive con with the what
the law actually uh says in terms of how
it impacts and multiple courts haven't
joined similarly worded statutes both in
federal court and the state court on
Magnus grounds in addition there have
been efforts to get the state to clarify
what specific texts are are and or are
problematic and the state has refused to
do so and so the effect of that is it
invites arbitrary and discriminatory
enforcement and that enforcement is
quite severe and includes loss of
teacher licensure which is a death
penalty for teachers in our state and it
also creates an entirely new right
private right of action for individuals
to actually school districts when they
feel that they have been aggrieved
there's also been talk about how the
guidance documents both the AG opinion
and the Department of Education guidance
documents are provide clarity
and I think it's important first of all
to note that the guidance documents are
not authoritative because under the law
the courts have independent are
independently charged with enforcing the
law and so the guidance documents don't
bind the court to do any specific thing
in fact there's a 35 year old New
Hampshire Supreme Court opinion
specifically on this issue that
clarifies that
let me just make sure I get the specific
language to y'all
that New Hampshire law can't be read to
have attorney general opinions
um substitute the uh the way that the
Judiciary will interpret a statute
um in addition
there's been both federal case law
um on the fact that when you have to
have administrative agencies providing
FAQ documents to clarify that that is in
fact quite good evidence of the
arbitrariness of the law that you're
having to have this administrative
agency trying to jump through all these
hoops to clarify I'm happy to answer any
questions I don't want to repeat
everything else that's or even said
that's in my testimony thank you very
much any questions yes go ahead
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
is there a way to amend this at all to
fill in all those gaps that you brought
up
um I we think the The Proposal on the
table hb61 is the right solution we need
to repeal this there is no way to amend
it is a vague law that is completely
arbitrary arbitrarily enforced and
people don't understand what it actually
says or means or how it actually impacts
the classroom and the result as you've
heard is that teachers are afraid to
teach
thank you
no we're not doing follow-ups so thank
you very much thank you yes you're
welcome
um the next card
I can't see that is it Gracie or
okay hi come on down
can you explain what AFS C is or L yes
absolutely so thank you esteemed members
of the committee for taking my testimony
my name is Grace condecke I wear many
hats I am the program coordinator for
the American friends service committee
which is a Quaker organization focused
on social justice and we have an office
here in New Hampshire I'm also a
longtime Manchester resident I've lived
in the granite state my entire life I
grew up here I was born in Congo in
Africa I came to the United States when
I was a toddler in addition to that I'm
also a property owner in a house that
was redlined I'm the first black
property owner of a house that was in a
historically Red Line Community
neighborhood in Manchester and I'm also
this year's MLK Martin Luther King award
recipient and so I'm proud to be here to
be able to speak in support of hb61 and
to share a little bit of both about the
unintended hacks I know a lot of our
colleagues here have talked about the
impact on Educators I'm also here to
share a little bit about the impact that
it has had on families of color with in
particular African immigrant families
with students in the public education
system who have been forced to make a
really difficult Choice knowing as
watching the state pass this law this
censorship law that has made it ever
more difficult for our children and our
communities to feel that they have a
safe place in our public education
system and that impact has included
families making the very painful and
difficult choice of whether or not to
send their children to expensive private
or religious schools in order to receive
the the to be able to get an education
that they would be able to understand
both of the full history of the country
as well as making the hard choice of
whether or not to send their children
out of state or out of the country in
order to be educated so that's some of
the unintended impacts of this bill
and so I want to have a few remarks and
I want to make sure to say that this
censorship bill as you've heard that for
others say has empowered hate groups and
hateful individuals who do believe and
operate from the belief that they are
inherently Superior due to their race
their gender or their sexual orientation
and act accordingly to threaten and harm
historically marginalized communities
and members of those communities I think
it is really important as we're talking
to understand CRT one of the other hats
that I wear is it is a university
student even at the grand old age of 35
I'm still working on my bachelor's
degree due to systemic injustices due to
being locked out of the education system
not because of my own Merit but because
of immigration status status and as well
as those are systemic inequities that
must be understood that must be
addressed in order for us to move
forward as a society and as a culture
and so in order to understand it one of
the things that my professors prompted
us and because CRT is taught most often
than not in the University level and it
is a framework to understand the ways
that our world is structured and so one
way to understand that is to think of
when your own life and your own self
when you fill out documents what
checkbox do you fill out why do you fill
it out when they ask you your
demographic your race what do you check
and why and if you can answer those
questions and you can understand that
that is CRT and so I know I hear the
buzzer and so I will conclude to say
that systemic racism sexism inequity is
devices is divisive because of the harms
that they cause not because they are
uncomfortable to learn about our
willingness to examine and discuss our
history in institutional
responsibilities enables us to fully
live into our values as a Granite State
and to realize the promises of the
Beloved Community that Dr King
envisioned and dreamed for us one one
that is United because we are willing to
courageously confront courageously
discuss courageously understand the
inequities and injustices no matter how
uncomfortable it is so please do the
right thing and vote ought to pass on
hb61 thank you thank you for your
patience today
the next person is Alyssa margoli
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is
Melissa margolin I'm here as a public
policy consultant to the New Hampshire
Center for non-profits we are in support
of HB 61 and I'd like to just give you a
summary of the testimony from the center
CEO Kathleen Reardon the center for
nonprofits has over 700 organizational
members and our role is to strengthen
and give voice to the state's nonprofit
sector
um we're in support of household 61 to
repeal and then revise RSA 193 colon 40
and repeal rsas three four 354a colon 29
through 354a colon 34. so New
Hampshire's nonprofits can offer their
best efforts to advance a more Equitable
future for all Granite Staters many of
our state's educational institutions
that bring national International
recognition to our great state are
non-profits and we have a duty to
improve our existing law so we can
offers and support diverse educational
experiences and encourage discussions
regarding the cap the challenges of past
and current discrimination we have
tremendous value in non-profit
educational institutions their value to
our state to our economy
and um the current law the de facto
impact is that it is uh it is providing
adverse consequences to providing that
quality education Community programming
and delivering a critical Workforce that
so many of us our businesses need
um the New Hampshire Center for
nonprofit strategic plan prioritizes
diversity equity and inclusion the
highly unpopular Amendment regarding
public discussions of discrimination
that was adopted in the last budget
undermines all of the nonprofits in our
state working on Dei
non-profits in New Hampshire are about
the common good whether it's about
showcasing the Arts in your community
providing Social Services
nonprofits are Community leaders we urge
the lawmakers to play their role in
creating a policy landscape that
encourages volunteerism Civic engagement
and allows non-profits to nurture New
Hampshire communities
concludes Our Testimony thank you very
much for your testimony today are there
any questions from the panel here now
see thank you
representative Dr Trinidad telez
good afternoon
good afternoon esteemed colleagues
I am Dr Trinidad Tellez a family
physician and public health practitioner
and now a representative from
Hillsborough District 40 representing
five Awards in Manchester
and here's a health professional
educator researcher and public servant
who served previously in the executive
branch for 10 years as director of The
Office of Health Equity at the
Department of Health and Human Services
I am also a 20-year resident of
Manchester and I identify as a Latina
person of color
in over 20 years working in the health
disparities Health Equity and now Equity
diversity and inclusion field I have
never seen or heard of any groups
and teaching that some groups are
inherently Superior to others and very
few people had even heard of critical
race Theory before these bills began a
few years ago and it is certainly not
taught in education settings and
workplace trainings
additionally we have learned the last
few years of the importance of believing
the experiences of people with
historically marginalized identities
whether they be women lgbtq individuals
people with disabilities immigrants
people of color and more and we have
heard all morning much and oftentimes
moving testimony of the current real and
damaging impacts resulting from the
passing of hb2 regardless of the words
that are ensconced in the written
language of the law we saw that business
employers understood the potential for
this when they turned out against the
language in the original HB 544 bill
because they understand that the
economic Vitality of New Hampshire
depends on embracing the current growing
diversity of the workforce and assuring
that everyone feels welcome and that
they belong additionally a democratic
citizenry must be informed and be able
to think critically learning history and
engaging with challenging Concepts is
not damaging rather as we've heard from
some of our wonderful Educators students
Thrive and are better prepared to be
successful adults and civically engaged
citizens especially in the increasingly
global economy and world I teach quality
improvement and the fundamental precept
is that we can't improve something if we
do not know where we're starting from
and where we are now is completely
informed and a result of what has
happened before in our country's history
I do not understand why we would choose
to prioritize ignorance which is not
knowing rather than seeking to
understand so we can constructively move
ahead as a society the significant
Health both mental and physical impacts
of stress and hostile workplace
environments and Community climates
cannot be emphasized enough every major
health health professional Public Health
Association such as the American Medical
Association and the American Public
Health Association understand that
racism is a Public Health crisis because
because of the profound differential
impacts of how racism is baked into our
systems and structures leaving groups of
people consistently suffering from worse
health and health outcomes in addition
to the direct impacts we're seeing in
people especially students and teachers
if we've heard earlier today these
problems cannot be appropriately
addressed by public employees who work
in public health and other health
sectors if they are Concepts that they
cannot fully engage with or be trained
in this is a disservice to our dedicated
public employees and the people of our
state so let's be clear the original
Bill were a solution to a problem that
did not exist however the very real
impacts of the law have created
unwelcome and hostile climates have had
chilling effects on Educators and public
employees and emboldened true racist and
discriminatory behavior from individuals
who want to silence and erase people of
color immigrants and other identities as
well as important learning and
conversations that are necessary to
ensure the New Hampshire Advantage for
years to come I urge you to vote on a
pass for hb61 thank you
any questions from the representative
thank you very much
representative Morton
thank you Mr chairman and committee for
the opportunity to speak today for the
record my name is Jen Morton I am a
representative from Hillsborough
District 34 in Amherst I'm speaking in
support of HB 61 hearing all the
testimony here today it has become
apparent that some of the members of the
committee do not understand how the
current RSA prohibits teachers from
engaging in classroom discussions of
social justice issues such as racial
race or gender but the truth is you
don't have to understand it you just
need to listen
I urge you to listen to all those who
are working under this law currently
listen to the overwhelming majority of
teachers social workers School
administrators parents students and
legislators who have testified here
today in support of hb61 we are telling
you the language and the current law is
vague
which opens the door for any student or
parent to Lodge a complaint that may
lead to an investigation
and a loss of a teacher's job that
threat is real
because of this teachers feel stifled
they feel discouraged the current RSA is
a teacher morale Destroyer
as I know you are well aware teachers
are leaving the profession at a rapid
rate I personally know personally no
three teachers who have left the
profession due to this law
hb61 is a step in the right direction in
improving the schoolwork environment
please trust our teachers please
recommend hb61 as ought to pass
thank you very much
and the last card right here you won the
lottery uh Ani Malaki who is the
executive director for the Human Rights
Commission here in New Hampshire
I might add that she wanted to be the
last
you got it
good afternoon everyone for the record
my name is Ani Malachi I'm the executive
director for the Human Rights Commission
excuse me getting over whatever is going
around in the air
I'm really here more for informational
purposes than anything else so there are
a couple of points that I'd like to make
one of the major ones is process I think
there's been some misunderstanding on
the process of how
if there is a charge of discrimination
how that works so I'd like to certainly
give information on that there is a
packet that I gave earlier and it has
handouts so that's what I'm going to be
providing my information from and I
think it was already brought down I
don't know if you all have that that
packet no
okay so I'll just go is it possible for
them to yeah take a few minutes to you
know just and then take us through it a
little bit
I can't hear you I'm sorry go ahead and
and just take several minutes to you
know give us the hype okay very good
um so as an initial Point
um the Human Rights Commission has the
authority of RSA 354a which are New
Hampshire's laws against discrimination
our jurisdictional area is public
education in general which was added in
2019 which I think is an important point
to make we also have jurisdiction over
employment public accommodation and
housing the commission was established
in 1965 and as you are all aware lost
change and things have been added to our
statute over time
um the commission is made up of a staff
of there's only eight of us at this
point so there are five investigators
that cover the entire State and all five
investigators work in all of our areas
of jurisdiction we have seven volunteer
Commissioners that help to adjudicate
our investigations once they are
finished
and
there is also a hearing panel so if
there's a case where there's a probable
cause finding then that that charge will
then move towards a public hearing
people can remove and go to court but if
they stay with the commission then then
there's a public hearing with three of
these seven
Commissioners and these would be three
Commissioners that have had no dealings
with the case at all so it is as the
lawyers would say de novo meaning the
Commissioners have not participated in
the investigation and it's brand new for
them so that the the both parties are
getting a fresh hearing on what's taking
place the initial cheat that is in that
packet on the top and you'll be able to
read through it later it's a white paper
very short and it goes through what our
process is so excuse me a charge comes
in
where a person makes an allegation and
we have the uh the uh
availability to either take that charge
in or pass on it and there's a legal
standard that has to be met first and
foremost now relative to
um the section in our statute and I
guess I should start or I should also
state that it's been referred to as the
divisive Concepts law the actual name of
the area in our statute is the right to
freedom from discrimination in public
workplaces and education and so that is
in our statute and RSA 354a section 29
through 34. so even though that is a new
area in our statute we use the exact
same process that we have always used to
move through and to receive a charge or
to pass on a charge once that charge is
taken in on Prima fascia meaning it
meets the legal standard then both
parties are notified well the charging
party obviously knows but the party that
would be the respondent is then notified
that there has been a charge of
discrimination based on these factors
once the party the responding party is
notified they have an opportunity to
respond to us it's a very administrative
process not unlike a court would be so
there it's not a someone has an issue
they come file a charge two days later
you're found you know there's an end to
that whether it's probable cause or no
probable cause and then something moves
forward in terms of for this situation a
teacher teacher's credentials
they have to go through our process
throughout the entire process so once
the file once the charge is filed the
parties are notified
excuse me the respondent
excuse me uh not contagious just a lot
of things happening in my lungs right
now and trying to talk is is an
interesting exercise so that means I
need to hurry up
um
so the respondent is notified they have
an opportunity to respond to the charge
and at that point if there is a
non-discriminatory reason why whatever
is being alleged happened we could be
done at that point
finished done
um once if that's not the case and we
move on to an investigation then the
parties are there's information gathered
from both parties an investigator is
going to ask questions have witnesses
and there could be uh sworn affidavits
that are part of the investigation then
there's a determination made a probable
cause no probable cause no probable
cause means we're done the investigation
is finished and
there could be a non-discriminatory
reason why something that the individual
is alleging took place and that is their
that is their reasonable defense for
what happened the person who's filed the
charge if they do not agree with our
finding of no probable cause they may
take that to court and appeal
if there's a probable cause finding then
what we do is both parties are notified
and then we move forward with scheduling
a hearing
um in in our in our offices
with our commissioners now the
respondent at that point can remove and
go to court yes sir we we do have a a
hearing starting up in about five
minutes okay so but go ahead alrighty so
um I mean I guess in a nutshell it's
very important I think for you all to
understand that the process for
adjudicating any charge under the um the
right to freedom from discrimination in
public workplaces and education follows
the exact same pathway as any other
charge that would come to our office
There's an opportunity for appeal
There's an opportunity for mediation
There's an opportunity for conciliation
which is just mediation after a probable
cause finding and one of the other
important elements is that the
Department of Education is devoid from
our entire process so in order for them
to even be involved there would have to
be a probable cause finding and then
then we would at that point if there
ever is one we would figure out what
that looks like and what that process is
so the Attorney General's office early
on provided an FAQ which is in the
packet that I provided to you which goes
through what is and isn't a foul of the
law and then subsequent to that I made a
request and the chair of the commission
made a request for the Attorney General
to give further clarification in case
people well people were still not clear
so there's additional information in a
much longer letter which is an opinion
and it was specifically requested
because an attorney general's opinion
which happens rarely in the state of New
Hampshire but that opinion would be
public and so that information
connected with the FAQ that was put out
would hopefully answer questions that
teachers or parents or Educators might
have ultimately
regardless of how you decide on this or
not I'm not advocating either way my job
is to advocate for the law so whatever
you decide is what I will do and my
staff will do ultimately there's a long
process that needs to be completed there
are opportunities for mediation and
conversation and and we continue with
Outreach and training and other efforts
to make sure that people understand
we're always available to answer any
questions so I'm sure I've forgotten 20
things but I think I've hit the high
points the packet does have all of this
information that I've reviewed within it
and I'm certainly available to answer
any questions but also if you would like
to reach out to me outside of this venue
and have a more detailed conversation or
I would be more than happy to have the
group of you come over or me to meet you
somewhere to do a more detailed training
whether it's on our process specifically
or what we do relative to education so
that this Clarity and understanding how
these things are adjudicated because
it's not just file put a put down a
piece of paper and then Bing bam boom
it's all over so thank you for your
patience and your Indulgence and I'm
happy to take any questions you might
have thank you are there any questions
from the committee
thank you director for the information
in the technical support
and understanding thank you very much
and this does close down our hearing on
hb60 yes
I can't give you that right now I do
know we had about 50 people testifying
and I would say close to 95 percent were
one way and five percent were the other
way
so I don't have that in front of me
right now I also don't have the blue
sheets in front of me they're all out
there and with that for the committee uh
close this hearing and for the committee
we are going to start the hearing a half
hour later
then it's posted it's posted on the door
over there at one o'clock we'll start at
1 30 and everything will be pushed off
by a half hour
thank you
foreign
okay we're ready to go ahead with the
second rendition here
second part of this affair today I want
to thank everybody for hanging in there
this morning on on 61 from 9 30 through
to when we stopped pretty much from one
o'clock
um so this afternoon we have two bills
131 and 35
131 is on the docket right now at the
top we did have the prime sponsor here
which was representative Mike Moffett
um he had to leave he had another
meeting he had to be at at this time so
we're going to have represent like us
who's also a sponsor on that bill
introduce the bill
so I rep I recognize represent like us
to introduce 131 this is Bill requiring
reports concerning school policies on
classroom recordings and in classroom
Observers
welcome
Hillsborough 38 now
um Hudson and Litchfield and I am
representing Mike Moffett
and I will be I know we're not supposed
to read testimony but it's not me it's
him and so I'm reading his testimony if
you don't mind go ahead he spoke with me
earlier and he said he couldn't be here
right maybe a half hour ago
right now he asked if you could read it
for him yes thank you Mr chairman
for the record on state representative
Mike Moffett representing Merrimack
District 9 which includes the lovely
town of Canterbury which features Shaker
Village and the lovely town of Loudon
which features Senator Howard Pearl's
maple syrup this measure is a reprise of
last terms HB 321 which is now law that
bill simply asks that school districts
share what if anything they're doing to
identify and support gifted students for
a best practices folder at the
Department of Education early
indications are that the gifted measure
is getting very good response as school
districts all over the state are now
having internal discussions on how to
better support that previously
underserved student population and with
no policy mandates or spending
requirement a real success story
this bill originally came to this
committee last year where it was
referred for interim study a study
committee held two lengthy sessions on
the measure and ultimately volunteered
to recommend OTP this full committee
subsequently also voted to OT to support
OTP when we met this past fall that's
referring to the other Bill not the
current one okay hb-131 similarly simply
asked school districts to share their
classroom observation policies as well
as audio video streaming and recording
with the Department of Education for
another best practices folder or virtual
folder doe Representatives indicated
that the department could support
implementation by using the template
currently in place for HB 321 the gifted
student law
attention to this area became important
during the covid pandemic when so many
schools went to hybrid in-class and
remote instruction some schools went
totally remote Nashua for example
closeded School doors over for over a
year
remote learning raised new questions in
numerous areas to include technology
issues cost issues access issues privacy
issues and legal issues what about homes
that do not have internet access or
families that don't have computers then
there's the issue of recording if a
student misses an online session what
are the ramifications if he or she of he
or she viewing a recorded version later
on are schools making Provisions for
recording and saving such sessions
I would point out that our committee
hearings are all being recorded and
saved on YouTube presumably in
perpetuity but these hearings differ
from classroom settings
many high school and college students
record or seek to record lectures for
future study and review purposes
teachers and professors typically
include recording protocols in their
syllabi but Educators who don't mind
their lectures being recorded sometimes
have issues with ubiquitous cell phones
so taping policies conflict with
recording policies
there are many pieces to our new world
of distance learning and hybrid
instruction that is why a best practice
is Folger in this area could be very
useful in the same way as the best
practices folder regarding gifted
students is developing into a wonderful
resource
then there's the classroom Observer
piece which ties into the media piece as
hybrid online or Zoom types of
instruction were observable by parents
and others when I was a classroom
teacher I'd get a occasional requests
from parents to sit in which was fine
but classrooms can only accommodate so
many visitors how do various school
districts deal with this issue
but when I taught no one had ever heard
of the internet for remote classes who
can tune in just students what if a
parent wants to watch what if the link
is shared widely
I don't have the answers only questions
this bill would help provide answers
Alternatives options and eventually
shareable best practices
again this measure includes no spending
requirements or policy mandates it
simply asks District to share existing
policies to create a best practices
folder if there are holes in existing
policies this measure provides the
impetus for them to be addressed locally
yes this could possibly be accomplished
via doe rules but the imprimatur of
State Statute matters greatly
Deb Hobson and I met with four doe
members including the commissioner on
this and they were all very supportive
this requirement could simply be easily
satisfied in a heartbeat with an email
and an attachment or link regarding
existing policies
if no policies exist regarding recording
or transparency issues then this measure
will provide a useful impetus to
districts to have overdue discussions to
eventually get some definition in this
new area of importance in 2023
again there is no policy mandate or
spending requirement between the Bill's
original hearing and then the two
interim study sessions and then another
discussion in ought to pass vote last
fall the issues associated with this
measure have already been addressed and
readdressed of course this committee
does feature some new faces
quite a few
I have already emailed a copy of these
remarks to the committee I want to
respond to questions if there are any I
do have to point out that I need to
introduce another worthy measure in
another committee at 1 30 PM but
fortunately co-sponsor Alicia leckis is
in the house and I'm sure she could help
address any questions as well thank you
and I'd be happy to take any questions
thank you very much uh represent
cordelli thank you Mr chairman uh thank
you for uh presenting uh representative
moffett's testimony
um I was just curious because we've
passed a number of statutes
um related to the requirement for
different policies uh to be passed by
local school districts this goes a step
further in requiring them to be sent to
the department for
um and I think the phrase was the
shareable best practices folder possibly
um but couldn't the same be said for
every policy that a school board has
probably
I thank you for the concise answer
um
I think the idea is that this is a new
area and there may be school districts
that have not yet come up with policies
and just by asking them to please send
in the policy
um that may get them to realize that oh
you know we haven't gotten around to
that yet maybe we should it's because
it's a new and important area that that
it's being done
I I have a question also and then maybe
others do as well
um we've had students absent from
schools
ever since I was school and before I was
born for various reasons and there's
always been a process for trying to make
that work up or to find out what went on
why is that not going to suffice now
when we're talking about some situations
like a grade school where there's a
whole lot of different directions going
on simultaneously
I don't think they're going to get it
from streaming so how is streaming going
to benefit the absence student
especially the elementary and the middle
school kid well I guess that's what
we'll find out okay because I mean this
isn't saying how to do anything all this
is saying is what are you doing
right and so that would be if a school
put in a policy whatever it was that was
very effective that could go in the
report we this is what we do and it's
very effective and then we would know
that other schools would know that and
might want to consider it yeah I had one
follow-up question not on that too do
did your group your sponsor which is
representative Moffett or yourself work
with the school boards Association to
determine if there's already boilerplate
uh policies out there which are
addressing this very issue
thank you I wasn't on that subcommittee
I know there were a lot of discussions
on it because this bill you know was
introduced last year
um and there may well be but the
question is has the school adopted them
you know just because there's something
available doesn't mean the school has
looked at it and adopted it so we want
to know you know have you adopted
something have you thought about this do
you have a policy that's that's okay
whatever that policy is and my next
question whose phone is going off
oh your blood pressure
[Laughter]
yeah my pressure's high too right about
me
are there any other questions perhaps in
a Luna thank you Mr chair
um thanks for taking my question uh you
know I think especially after the the
hearing on House Bill 61
um I'm uh I'm interested in obviously
interested in this bill and interested
um who would have access to this um
collection of policies regarding
um classroom recordings and and
particularly in classroom Observers I
think
that would be up to the doe it's not
specified
I mean they would have to come up with
the item and I'm not sure what they did
with the gifted bill but they would have
to come up with rules regarding that I
don't think we're asking for anything
that's
um wouldn't be possible to be public
you know we're not asking how do you
observe people in the hallways and keep
track of that kind of thing we're asking
for their policies for in classroom
videoing and for visitation and so
that's not going to be
um things that have to do with safety
further follow-up thanks thanks very
much and I I I I I have my notes from
last year's Bill and there were
certainly concerns that had to do uh
with safety from from Public Safety
professionals and um and school building
safety professionals so so I don't feel
that what you just said is really an
expert opinion but where did you where
did you where does that opinion come
from
where it doesn't have anything to do
with safety because
we're not talking about like
I agreed with you last time right when
it came to the whole what all are we
videoing and that kind of stuff are we
watching people in the hallways all of
that which is not what the this is
actually asking for
currently are we doing I mean in
classroom recording is different than
what we're doing for
um
supervision and that kind of stuff and
so follow-up okay sure given the fact
that any random person can carry a
loaded weapon into a public school
building uh do you find any pause when
it comes to Public Safety about having
any one person being able to have access
to a collection of policies with respect
to what I can do in terms of entering a
school building and sitting in the back
of the classroom and observing
um
yes no risk
if it has to do with what any random
person can do I mean
I would hope
I can see if the school's policy was
anybody who wants to can walk in and sit
in the back of the classroom that they
might not want that to be public I doubt
that any schools have that but yes so I
I see your concerns
further questions representative
McDonald thank you how does this bill
accommodate schools who may not be able
to provide a policy because it's at the
teacher's discretion so it might vary
from teacher to teacher from school to
school within the district then that
would be the policy okay thank you it's
teacher discretion
I I doubt that a superintendent would we
put a report out and maybe that's
because I have confidence in them that
they wouldn't put a report out that was
such detail that it explains exactly how
they do videoing and everything but just
a policy saying this is public this is
not public students can see it students
cannot see it you know students can tape
it students cannot tape it I mean we're
not talking about all the little details
we're just talking about a general
overview and for most schools who have
policies like that it's already
um if they have the policy it's probably
already in the student handbook and
that kind of thing so at any rate but
yes I see your your and if and if you
have a way of addressing that I would
love to hear it maybe we can amend this
I I've got a question which I'd like to
ask you and follow up to where we are
right now on policy is there a
definition of policy here now policy
where I've always been an administrator
has been made by this school board there
are certain rules or regulations
handbooks developed locally within a
school regarding Sports participation
um what we do in a disciplinary
situation that you know Echoes and
oftentimes adjusts with the board policy
on it as well so is there what exactly
are you looking for are you looking for
board policy on these issues or are you
looking at procedures developed within a
school
or both
um it may be that the school just
follows the board policy if the school
has particular ones from one school to
another and they haven't passed it
through the board like you said the
board usually develops policies then it
would be nice to know what those were
are those board policies and I have a
superintendent sitting at the table
right now when you pass a board policy
it's a public thing exactly so it's
already known well that's what I'm
saying what we're expecting is a public
policy but who knows it they're public
not the rest and apparently it's if they
haven't adopted a policy this is to get
them to think about it I mean really
that
for me now I don't know about for the
bill sponsor but for me as the
co-sponsor for me it was just schools
should have policies on this because
there's a lot of complicated issues and
do they
and so by saying you need to report your
pilot you know you need to send in your
policy it's just a way of getting this
school or the district or whatever to
say huh
we don't actually have a policy on this
maybe we should this is my last question
I'm sure the follow-up to that
is it the responsibility the legislature
who writes laws
to be the party that is now saying you
got to do this this and this other words
we're sort of closing in on the
executive responsibilities when we're
telling them you know
we know that they have a policy but now
we're telling them what they've got to
do with these policies
um is that our domain or is that more
the domain for example of the
commissioner of Education well do we
have a bill that says that they have to
have this policy
okay
what was that absolutely he's right on
that recordings we absolutely do have
policy which we pass in fact
representative cordelli be glad to tell
you that episode
um which was a really trying time we
took us a couple years to get it right
um so uh
thanks for bringing that up
[Laughter]
yeah you got it right my question is is
probably a naive question because I
don't know if it's applicable in K-12
but in universities it's entirely common
when visiting speakers come if they
require no reports as part of their
contract because that's their business
they didn't want anybody selling it on
site obviously but you know poets and
writers and people like that will make
these presentations but no recording
permitted I don't know who's the
authority under which that is said at
the institution though so
I throw that out for what it sounds like
a policy to me well but I mean you don't
have Outsiders writing your policies I
mean this is the visiting speaker but
that that's his part of the contract but
somebody has to ratify that and say okay
no no and tell everybody else no
recording
I I think at this point forward you know
we're starting to get into the decision
so questions so if you guys have any
great amendments for this that that's be
great how to keep it safety issues out
of it all of that kind of stuff
please thank you very much
representative yes
thank you just a quick question
wondering if the bill sponsor or
yourself have already investigated what
the best practices are and how they are
shared amongst the professional
education Community but as I said the
these Prime sponsors I read his thing
said that he doesn't have answers yet
and I myself have talked to lots of
people trying to come up with what best
practices are and there's all kinds of
well it'd be really great if we had the
teacher recorded but on the other hand
then you could inadvertently get
students and that violates privacy and
put students out and Etc et cetera so
it's a very complicated issue which I
think was part of the Prime sponsor's
ideas it's a very complicated issue and
maybe if somebody has some brilliant
ideas it would be a chance for others to
see them
thank you are there further questions of
Representative Lucas
okay the next person which we have thank
you
representative is Becky Wilson from the
New Hampshire school boards Association
the organization has all these
boilerplate policies
here but because of the length of this
document
s
thank you
you can share a good one Jenkins too
uh good afternoon Becky Wilson of the
New Hampshire school boards Association
thank you for allowing me to speak on
this bill today we are not going to take
a position specifically on this bill as
last year when a very similar bill came
to this committee we simply offered
information as to what is already
available to this committee and to the
general public in terms of school
district policies around video audio
classroom observations visitor policies
Etc so that's what I've brought with me
today
there were several questions raised last
year in terms of what is available with
sample policies Etc current practices of
school boards and I think to the
sponsors Point earlier originally I
think this bill came forward as a result
of some concerns that came to light in
the middle of the covid pandemic and
some of the changes and practices at
that time we did advise our members not
specific to create policies that were
driven from a pandemic lens our belief
is that policies are meant to withstand
a pretty extensive amount of time in a
number of different circumstances not
specifically to one kind of situation
that is not in our opinion the intention
of policies there were a lot of daily
practices in schools over the last few
years that did change in response to the
covet pandemic and they were different
in every community and they were in
response to that community's needs at a
given time
based on the communities
decision and the community's input onto
what kinds of practices and day-to-day
procedures would be happening at the
school in light of CDC health concerns
availability of internet in different
parts of the state Etc so we would
continue to sort of go down that road
and support the fact that policy should
not be written specific to the covid
pandemic in isolation there are a number
of policies that we have given out as
sample policies that address all of
these kinds of concerns in terms of
audio and video surveillance the
difference between that and teachers
recording a classroom or an experiment
for example for an assessment purpose or
for teachers observation reflecting
Reflections as part of their evaluation
process the difference between
surveillance audio and video
and video for some other purpose
schools have to have a policy and an
ability for parents to consent to audio
and video and circumst certain
circumstances outside of things like
busing Etc all of those policies are
sample policies that we provide to our
members and the intention of those
sample policies is for districts to take
them and tailor them to their specific
needs to the questions that had come up
earlier we have three types of sample
policies policies that are required by
law that school boards must have
policies that are recommended in light
of current laws and policies that are
optional that schools can or cannot take
up we would also say that the majority
if not all of our school districts that
our members have all of their policies
posted publicly online on their website
so if there's a question that somebody
wants to go in and see what a certain
District requires as part of their
policies we would say that most of those
are available go ahead and look at those
I'm not sure that collecting all of the
policies at the department would serve
any different purpose than what people
could already access
and superintendents are not the ones
that would be responsible so to speak
for creating the policies that is a
school board
um responsibility so
I'm happy to take any questions in
regards to these things but
also requiring that any changes to the
policies then be sent to the department
annually well I realize that doesn't
seem like a very big task in some of our
districts it's just one more report that
the superintendent's office is going to
have to try to keep track of from the
previous November What policies might
have been adjusted that would
potentially contain anything to do with
observations visitors to schools audio
video surveillance Etc it just seems
like maybe it's not
going to serve the purpose that the
original
Bill's intent was meant to cover
um
any questions I'm happy to take them
rips and Ellison
um thank you Mr chair Becky thank you
for being here get your clarification
you just said that most school districts
have most of their policies
publicly posted uh if a school district
has a policy on classroom recordings you
assume that's that's part of the package
you're talking about
thank you for the question yeah yes I
would I mean
school boards post their policies
publicly they talk about them publicly
in board meetings they have multiple
readings of those policies at school
board meetings which are all public so
anything that's contained within that
policy and that policy itself once it's
approved in our experience would be
posted with all of the other policies
that are approved there is a difference
between
policy School Board policy and daily
practice and procedures at the school
level and I think that's speaking to
what some people on the committee have
were mentioning earlier
um you know the day-to-day practice the
procedure of what happens when kids get
off the bus at the building level is not
necessarily a policy that is a daily
practice that might be different from
building to building or maybe in some
cases from teacher to teacher depending
on what the administration allows for
that but again it's going to meet the
policy that the board has passed
whatever those daily practices are
Rick
oh a quick follow-up Vicky then
just done theoretically uh of 80 of the
school districts in the state have
public policies on classroom recordings
and they're now public
seems to me we pretty much have our
folder of best practices right there
thank you it was not a question
I got a question for you short Friends
of the board for the board uh we we've
gone and done a similar thing with the
gifted
a passes for that you have send them to
doe do you know what doe maybe we have
doe present now in the room do you know
if doe has made these available or are
they just sitting on somebody's desk at
doe and not serving any kind of a a
purpose thank you for the question but I
really can't answer that that would be
better directed to the Department
okay then the follow-up question for you
are the policies which you have which
are boilerplate that you passed out here
um are they available to all districts
via the web do you have them available
so you I could if I'm a superintendent I
just punch it up and there it is thank
you for the question yes all of our
members are just our board member
districts
um have a password protected access to a
file that contains all of our sample
policies and the majority of
superintendent Sports have allowed their
superintendents to also have access to
that yes thank you welcome
further questions
not seeing thank you very much thank you
is there any other testimony on the bill
not seeing any we're going to close this
hearing oh we won Diane oh come on up
yeah
let's get this
other questions
good afternoon for the record my name is
Diana Fenton I'm an attorney with the
Department of Education I did not fill
out a pink card so I'm in violation of
some sort of Regulation I'm sure but I'm
happy to answer any questions as it
pertains to the bill before this
committee we don't have regulations we
have rules perfect even better
okay the question I had that when we
passed the gifted Bill trying to get
these policies in from schools and the
concept was that there'd be all those
would all be available to various school
districts and looking at maybe best
practices
what's the process that the department
has right now you've received them
what's being done with them thank you
for the question it's a great question
if you remember the Department's
testimony when the gifted bill was being
brought forward which came forward in a
couple of sessions I think it went
forward once it was studied and that
came forward again so there's a long
history to that bill but the
Department's testimony was in part a
concern as to what does this committee
want the department to do with this bill
with this information there is a long
history of bills being passed where the
department will collect information
gather information but there's no uh
direction as to what the department does
with this and so the department for some
time went into a habit of collecting
paper and putting it in folders and
certainly representative Ellison used to
work in the department can can speak to
that as well as I and so the
Department's testimony in particular
with the gifted and talented bill was
what is the role of the department what
is the expectation and initially it was
supposed to be paper copies
um now it's electronic and my
understanding is that it is on our
website it is available uh there are no
reports being put into folders that are
being put in someone's desk it is on our
website available
um for people to to utilize and that was
done for a purpose it was it was done as
part of discussion with this committee
as I testified over the summer when this
bill was in interim study
um again the department would request
guidance from this legislative body as
to what role the department is to play
but I think the idea would be we would
create a similar format for these
reports as we did for gifted and
talented
uh thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question so earlier we talked
I think maybe before you came into the
room sure the issue about security
as it relates to these particular
policies uh and if the department were
to collect these and post them on their
uh website do you see any concern about
potential breach of the security around
this
my understanding of the bill is that
these would all be policies that are
public information anyway
so certainly the hope would be that
there would not be any breach because
these are public documents that would
remain public
um
you know if there is anything
confidential and I I'm thinking of the
school safety reports and
um
School emergency plans forgive me the
school emergency plans
my understanding of that law is the
department does not collect those we're
not a first responder obviously and so
we took Great Lengths in that particular
Bill to exclude having those documents
those blueprints of school buildings
anything that could be related to safety
so I think if we were to follow the
model that we follow for gifted and
talented they would have to already be
public documents
that we would then make public
of San Luna
thanks very much and um and a follow-on
to representative myler's question
um
do you do you have any concerns with
respect to General Public Access not to
individual public documents but to a
Statewide collection of public documents
so that a one person could make one you
know dip into a website get a Statewide
portfolio of schools that permit in
classroom observers and then doing
whatever they want to do with that next
I appreciate the question I'm not
entirely sure how to answer it I I know
where you're going with that question
the idea being it's a culmination of
documents and how can that be used and
the answer is I
I'm not able to speculate as to how that
could be used for for a bad purpose I
understand the intent of the bill is to
just make it readily available for
people to get best practices and
policies
um could it be used for bad purpose I
suppose it could you're asking a former
criminal prosecutor so I I'm always
going to have that view of the world but
I certainly understand the intent of the
bill and it's been discussed at length
especially over the summer and I think
the idea was a best practice folder
similar to gifted and talented students
thank you Mr chair and thanks again
Diana sure um I'm sorry I didn't thank
you last time for uh for taking
questions it was inferred so so if we if
we can sort of reflect back then on the
um the the gifted and talented
um uh information
um who has access to that right now and
um and how much access has there been so
far to that collection of data I will
answer your second question first I'm
not sure how much access
um
I'm not sure how many people have
utilized it I know that it took a while
for the Department to
um get the website up and running simply
because the bill had a pretty long
effective date
and so I think when we were talking
about the gifted and talented bill being
up and running we weren't quite there
yet so we were working towards it but
there was an effective date that that we
were guiding our work by
um so I have reason to believe that it
is up and running I can't tell you how
many people have accessed it but like
all resources on our website people
utilize them when they need them and
then we go from there but I can look to
see if we have a number but I certainly
don't have that information right here
you're very welcome
are there further questions represent
Woodcock thank you Mr chairman good
afternoon Teresa and just a quick
question John the people who access doe
websites albeit the one that regards the
give them talented or you know to the
doe track who does that who actually who
actually access to that website not to
the best of my knowledge and I I'm
that's fine I was probably going to show
how computer illiterate I am I I don't
know how we would do that
um I I don't think we have the ability
to do that and to the best of my
knowledge we we don't we don't do that I
mean our website is a public State
website thank you
thank you are there any other further
questions for the Department
thank you thank you very much
that will close our hearing for 131
and we have one other bill this
afternoon that's HB 35
and hb35 is a bill I meant a bill on the
C
we get here in front of me here
I know it deals with eating disorders
I'm looking for the title of it on here
I guess I'm missing a sheet here
okay the the bill title is requiring
student identification cards to include
the national Eating Disorders hotline
okay so yeah so the primary sponsor that
bill
once again I don't have that one so
as represent wrong yes you're here
welcome thank you
yeah let's first have you introduce the
bill and then we can invite him up okay
yeah
thank you very much
the red button the button yeah there you
go thank you
thank you very much
thank you very much ah there we go thank
you very much for allowing me to
introduce HB 35. this bill came to my
attention in late August when a
constituent of mine Matthew Brown who is
currently a freshman at Merrimack High
School asked if I would file it and it
is to add the helpline for the national
Eating Disorders Association to all
student identification cards and at that
time
um you know I think those of us
especially have been in the house for a
while the last thing we want to do is
file a bill that solves a problem that
we don't have so I asked Matthew to
submit a problem statement for me to
explain why the spill is needed and what
the outcome would be and two things came
to mind as soon as I read that uh once
he returned it to me as one is he would
make a great committee researcher for
the New Hampshire house so we need to
keep that in mind in a few years and
second of all this is a profound problem
I was not aware of how extensive and how
serious and how deadly Eating Disorders
are
in fact there's
um
you know just those that suffer from
bulimia
youth are eight to nine times more
likely to die than from suicide than
their peers in fact Eating Disorders is
the second leading cause of suicide
um and and especially death among these
youth so I I realize the committee may
have a concern well why should we add
this helpline why is this uh you know
what about all these other helplines
that that could be added to student IDs
you know are we opening up the
floodgates but we recognize already how
important it was to have the suicide
helpline on student IDs and eating
disorders feeds into that considerably
you're going to hear data from Matthew
about how extensive this is but if we
can address Eating Disorders through the
most vulnerable and largest population
of victims we can actually really reduce
the numbers of suicide that we
experience
I I got to the committee room
it's Amendment 2023-0020h
and this amendment
um
is a result of conversations I've had
with people at the national Eating
Disorders association their concerns
were they prefer the word helpline over
hotline and they also were concerned by
having a specific number there that it
might be changed in the future so I I
took that that information to heart and
then also yesterday morning I had a
conversation with the government Affairs
director for the community colleges of
New Hampshire the Community College
systems of New Hampshire Shannon Reed
and she raised concerns to me too
although she support they support the
intent of the of the original bill they
have concerns that
um it would be very difficult to
implement and I'm sure all of us have
seen well-intentioned bills that pass
but failures in implementing them
effectively prevent us from seeking the
positive outcomes that we had initially
hoped for that bill so the student IDs
at the second alert the secondary level
are much different than those we see at
middle and high school they include
keyless entry software meal plan so much
information and software on those ID
cards and they're only issued once every
two years or four years depending on the
institution so it it didn't seem like it
would be as effective including
post-secondary schools in with this bill
so I you will see that Amendment takes
out any
requirement of post-secondary Education
institutions to include that helpline it
includes the uh the change in the
wording to helpline and it also takes
out this specific phone number but just
asks you know it just says please
confirm the exact number when these
cards are produced and then the last
change I made to it is that I recognize
that if this bill makes it way to the
governor's desk it may not be it may not
become effective until when school
districts are already in their new
fiscal year and they may have already
ordered student cards to use to issue so
it's made so that when new cards are
ordered or produced that's when that
number would have to be included so if
let's say you know fingers crossed the
bill passes I don't want to jinx it but
let's say you know it passes in Late
July when districts have already ordered
their set of cards they wouldn't be
required to replace those
so
um that is the you know the the the
um summary of the bill
um the you know what the desired outcome
is is to reduce the number of Youth
suicides and not even get to the point
where our youth has suicide ideation
that if they're suffering from an eating
disorder they have a very convenient
accessible direct way to seek help one
that protects their anonymity they don't
have to share this information with you
know their with their concerns with
other people but they can they can get
the help right away
so I would be happy to answer any
questions you have many of your
questions may be better suited to have
Matthew Brown
um answer those so I don't know if he
would be welcome to come up at this
point Mr chair we're going to take the
other Representatives first oh okay just
the courtesy which we have
um so are there any questions of
represented wrong yes representative
Cornell Thank you thank you for taking
my question I and I may be wrong but I
think the suicide and crisis Lifeline
number the 911 has counselors that
answer the phone and they deal not only
with suicide but if it's any emotional
crisis they'll make referrals to the
appropriate
Agency number or whatever and I and do
you think that would not be as fast as
getting another number
um on the thing but just call it the
9-1-1 and get the referral like I think
to the appropriate because it's not just
for suicide it's suicide and crisis
Lifeline so they could make we you know
call and tell them what the problem is
and they'll refer you to the correct
agency thank you representative Cornell
for the question
you know it presenting a bill like this
it's important to understand who our key
audience is and for an adult that would
be very reasonable but for someone in
adolescence they're not going they may
not think that they're at risk for
suicide they may not think they are even
having a mental health issue but if they
see the word eating disorder they're
more likely to to make that call also
when it's a call and it they're they're
they don't have to wait on a referral
they they there's an immediacy they may
decide to call just on the spur of the
moment it may be very spontaneous so for
an adolescent who's suffering from an
eating disorder that's spiraling
um getting a quick easy number for what
they recognize is only an eating
disorder is probably going to have a
higher rate of connection than if they
said oh Suicide Hotline or Mental Health
crisis line they may not even identify
with that as they would in eating
disorder and I think
talking to students that's what I
learned from them as well
yes thank you for the question I have a
question
um a young person take a middle school
kid I'll take that age bracket
they are already into maybe the anorexia
and bulimia
but they don't recognize that they don't
recognize that they so how do we deal
with this student that doesn't even
recognize that they have this eating
disorder
they're not going to call yeah thank you
for the question representative Vlad I
think I I I'm not an adolescent those
days are long gone for me but I think
some a an adolescent suffering from
bulimia or anorexia is probably going to
recognize that isn't it has to do with
eating yeah you know like eating
disorder they may see that as an
obsession they have with food so I I
would think that they would relate more
to the word eating disorder even if they
don't directly identify
um that that is like a likely diagnosis
they would have
um and I I think that they would relate
to that more than they would suicide or
mental health or crisis
I don't know I I think you know it would
be interesting to talk just a little
differently with the question and did
you consult with medical Physicians or
hospitals Etc that have
uh support for this type of uh illness
and ask the question what about these
young people
that my observation as a school
administrator when I saw this happening
is they they didn't see it at the kids
yet didn't see that as an issue
that it came later in their life uh when
it was impairing so many of the other
functions of the body
so my concern is will the kids use this
card
of a young age
I I expect so and let me tell you the
reason as I Was preparing this bill
um I had a conversation with a friend of
mine who is a pediatrician for a large
Southern New Hampshire practice
and I said I want to you know get your
feedback on eating disorders and she
said it's very coincidental that you
bring that up because we have seen a
huge increase in the past three months
um parents have called because they've
noticed an extreme weight loss in their
child or if she's having a a a
appointment with with one of her
patients and she may notice that you're
losing weight and a conversation it's
something they
um may not recognize on their own but
they may hear from their parents or
their teachers about you know I think
you have a I think there's an issue
going on I think you may have an eating
disorder and it may put something in
their head that then they can relate to
with the hotline I did review the online
testimony on this bill I don't know if
any of you have but there was a written
testimony submitted by a school teacher
I don't really know where she was but
she also supported this bill because she
recognizes the issues with her students
and she believes that this hotline will
be helped will be a resource to them
okay thank you yes representative
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question I want to um piggyback on
what representative Cornell said um the
988 hotline was a response to
incorporate suicide and mental health
and substance abuse disorders and in an
effort to make it simpler for people to
get to and I just wonder if adding
another full number is kind of
counterintuitive to the way that that
that's trending
thank you for the question
representative dry as I mentioned before
I think how we might respond to seeing a
number like that may be different than
what an adolescent responds to they may
see that that that General number or the
the the uh
Clearinghouse number as something that
doesn't relate to them they're really
just looking specifically at Eating
Disorders they may have you know been in
conversation with their parents or their
teacher or their friend's parents who
might have suspect they have an eating
disorder I don't think that that
realization that they need help would
would connect with them to that a
Clearinghouse where they could more
easily collect something specific for
eating disorders
um and I do recognize that you know
there are a lot of helplines out there
but when you look at the numbers of
eating disorders and how it in in fact
more students of color and more students
in the LBGTQ Community have a much
higher rate of suffering from suicide or
dying from suicide it's because they've
suffered from eating disorders so it's
almost as though we look at Eating
Disorders as just a very specific
helpline but it really can Encompass so
many other
um issues because that are manifested in
eating disorders
thank you as a further question
representative Woodcock thank you Mr
chairman from the wrong good afternoon
thank you um thank you for taking my
question of two of them to Chairman
loudly uh in uh line uh one actually of
your Amendment you you talked about
grades six I was trying to figure out uh
two things if school not that they would
be applicable particularly at grades one
to six but do school give out uh ID
cards the youngsters of the students in
grades one through five
not to my knowledge in fact I'm pretty
sure they don't because I've been
serving as a substitute in those grades
kindergarten through grade four and now
this has only been in the Merrimack
School District but I there I don't see
any student IDs but I do know
um the middle school does and the high
school does I I praise that because I
was thinking about what representative
Ladd had if I think Matt what were other
than that had indicated uh asking about
if students knew or could identify if
that was a disorder at their grade I'm
assuming that in the Middle School
curriculum for health officer they
receive some initial dialogue understand
discussion in that piece so I want to go
about the parent
who may um see a youngster student uh
his ID and recognize that their child
has the issue uh and also use that so
this point why why if it would be more
applicable to have student IDs period
K-12 but when if whatever you wherever
you agree the school system implements
them that that would be on there versus
starting at grade six so if in uh
Margaret's school with grade five and
grade seven but once the school district
Implement period that that extended
thing I'm saying yes I see six that's
all that that was like that so I was
wondering why you picked six in
particular
um I picked six because I believe that
and thank you for the question
um I I believe that was the grade for
the suicide helpline that was in the
previous last year's legislation
um and just to my knowledge that's
usually Indica indicative of Middle
School Age and and I do know IDs are
issued for I believe most middle schools
now I mean there's nothing that prevents
a school that may offer IDs at a younger
age from putting it on it's just they
wouldn't be compelled to by Statute I
was thinking okay if an amendment would
follow the ad hat that the school ID
period is not great so it is there I was
thinking more of the parent of a middle
school young service homeless to see
that in our grade five child can see
this oh wow thank you that's all thank
you thank you Mr chair thank you
uh representative Ford
yes thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question is there a parallel
yeah excuse me is there a parallel or
tandem process by which parents are
advised of this not maybe specifically
their child but in the eighth grade we
begin to notice sort of no thing that
goes out to them that makes them aware
of the same concerns not maybe
specifically to their child but to
children in that age group or that
series of uh areas of age and grade
level that you're concerned about do
they get pulled into this notification
um thank you very much for the question
representative Ford
um I don't unless they have a child that
has an ID card that they may look at and
notice that this this helpline is
printed I'm not sure they would be aware
of it unless they actively sought out
maybe you know searched on the internet
under Eating Disorders one thing I
learned from my friend is that many
people will call you know if they have a
concern they may reach out to their
physician and say I you know I'm
concerned my son or daughter's friend
seems to be losing weight is there
anything I can do or is there you know
may reach out if or give them some
advice or information they might share
with the parent or Guardian
um but this really just pertains to the
student IDs
I understand uh that and thank you it
just struck me that maybe there was a
way to reach them through a side door as
well yeah
well also I mean I I am aware and this
is after you know
you know work on the bill is that you
know schools and curricula do do
communication and education on on eating
disorders in general
I think and and I hope after reading the
the research that I've done and I I did
email everyone a copy of some of the
most prominent research academic
research uh I emailed that out last
night my source is for this data but um
I anticipate there's going to be a lot
more communication on this because it is
a it's very extensive and serious
problem I mean to be the number one
cause of number one number two I forget
if opioid addiction where that stands
but eating disorders is a major
um uh reason for suicide
thank you are there further questions
I've represented wrong I'm seeing thank
you very much thank you very much uh
representative Tanner are you going to
testify on this one
okay someone is wrong thank you chairman
lad uh for the record I'm representative
Linda Tanner Sullivan number five
the towns of Sunapee and Springfield
and as a 35-year teacher of health and
physical education and coaching many
women's sports over the over the time
that I was working
um Eating Disorders were probably the
most frustrating and difficult to deal
with and I know that um representative
Damon is up next to me
um and she's a health professional who's
dealt with eating disorders so I'm sure
she can give you a lot of information
I think my job here is just to tell you
that it is a big problem
body image is a huge problem with kids
both boys and girls sometimes we think
it's just a girl's problem but it's it
relates to boys as well it often starts
out with experimenting a little bit
about
um or worried about their your own body
size and then it just it snowballs on
them and oftentimes uh by the you know
it changes their brain
patterns it changes a lot of things in
their life and the parents are usually
um from from my experience as frustrated
with it as anybody
um because it's it's just a a super
difficult thing to deal with
um it's a very secretive problem kids as
I said kids will start out kind of um
experimenting with their food intake or
throwing up bulimia
um exercising was another thing
um you know that I the some of the
people that were really into Eating
Disorders uh badly into it really wanted
to exercise all the time and it's a very
lonely
disorder and so a lot of these kids are
very isolated
um
their
their having difficulties on a lot of
different levels and
um they often won't ask for help and if
someone mentions something about their
body image it just makes things worse
and they they guard against it
um so I think a hotline like this was is
a great idea when Rosemarie presented it
I thought it was a great idea I think it
would also be a great idea to have
posters around and also in maybe the
student parent handbook as
representative Ford had because even
though we have a suicide hotline and we
have a general 9-1-1 emergency hotline
and I really and I super super support
those and realize what good they do
um
and I think even last year when we had
the suicide hotline and and putting on
the cards was a great idea
um having something that's just eating
disorders where immediately they don't
go through two or three levels of people
referring them to somebody else because
it's a with kids it's a spur of the
moment thing they they suddenly get to a
crisis situation or something happens
that keys with them that something's
drastically wrong and it might even be a
friend who is very concerned about
another friend
um at that point if they have something
in their hand if they know something and
it's right there and they can they can
get to it and it's going to be
um responsive right away I think it's
it's really great and I would suggest as
we did with suicide lines that um and I
looked to the um add-on TV that says you
know I'm trying not to be my parents but
I think
um texting and chat are really big on
the on this level versus telephoning
that's kind of old school now so I think
if there's a text number or if there's a
way for them to enter into a chat
um then they get immediate response and
it's with a professional who knows just
about eating disorders so I guess my
main thing is to just say yes it is a
problem I dealt with it many many times
um
it was frustrating uh
oftentimes it um it didn't resolve in
suicide but it was a lifelong problem
I'm still in contact with one of the
young ladies that was on a tennis team
and she still struggles with it as an
adult I mean she's got to be in her 50s
now
um and so it it's a lifelong thing and
it can affect in later life osteoporosis
it becomes really a big major problem
and all their organs have problems with
it as well so I urge all of you to
support this and I'm hoping through a
couple of amendments we can even make it
better thank you are there any questions
for representative Tanner
Griffin Woodcock thank you Mr chairman
brother Terry it's a quick question in
your career in the health domain not the
physical education domain at what grade
level did you start integrating uh
Dialogue on uh Eating Disorders well the
the problem is it starts very early I
mean now we're finding or hearing about
uh young people you know
um
second first second grade actually being
cons or even before that watching TV and
being concerned about their body image
and and what all of a sudden what
they're eating I mean usually in the old
times it was trying to get them to you
know it was uh or get them off junk food
or something like that but now it's a
problem and so you know they they see
that they kind of think well you know
they hear a little bit about it and then
by the time they get to Middle School it
can be so ingrained I mean it gets to a
point where their brain chemistry
changes so much from the eating disorder
that they they can stand in front of a
mirror and actually be look like a
skeleton and pick skin out and say it's
fat
um and they have they lose I mean the
tennis player one of the things with
that struck me was in high school tennis
we call our own lines
um you don't have referees like you do
in basketball and soccer and stuff like
that and I would have complaints by the
other team that this girl was called
just terrible at calling the lines and
um would sit down talk with her and and
she really couldn't
she couldn't make that decision and
oftentimes I mean it wasn't that she was
trying to do it on purpose or anything
she just it her vision and what she
could see and her perception was totally
skewed
um particularly when she was in a crisis
and hadn't eaten and well we all know
that if we hadn't eaten in a while you
know how dizzy you can get and
dehydrated you can get and and uh shaky
and it happened to her so yes it it goes
a lot lower so it's a point I was when I
get through a real lost
um curriculum wise when did Health
instruction in in great saves Grace that
when did Eating Disorders begin
currently today is your best knowledge
when is it integrated into the
curriculum
I think health is one of those areas
that um hasn't totally been integrated
into the elementary schools and is a
political football like some of the
other things so
um I would say that hopefully there's
some integration at the at the
elementary school but I'm not sure that
it's happening and I would say at Middle
School level that's probably where they
first hear about anything thank you Mr
chairman thank you further questions of
Representative Tanner
thank you very much thank you you're
welcome
so we uh represent Damon did you feel
are you going to testify today
do you have a card over there
no I mean but they they're
well come on up and speak and then if we
can't we can always do a duplicate
good afternoon thank you Mr chairman
thank you to the committee and to
everyone attending to this very
important issue I'm representative of
Hope Damon Sullivan County District 8
I'm going to save listing the nine towns
between Croydon Claremont and Acworth
I am a registered dietitian I retired at
the end of December 22.
um
35 years of my work were in private
practice
I would say about a third of my patients
were
referred to me or self-referred for
eating disorders care
and probably
another 20 to 30 percent were people
referred for a different diagnosis who
turned out to also have an eating
disorder
if you hear my voice shaking it's both
because I am so passionate about this
topic and it's hard to
bring Decades of
very challenging and very rewarding work
into three minutes
so bear with me
I consulted for Colby's for a college
Proctor Academy the local public schools
a little bit for Kua and Dartmouth
Dartmouth ultimately hired their own
dietitian full-time to work with
students on nutrition issues mainly
Eating Disorders which I think
represents
some degree of how present this
situation is
supporters are not necessarily visible
I counted heads in this room a few
minutes ago we're around 35 or 40 people
I can tell you without looking anywhere
and not knowing most of these people at
all
there are probably five people in here
right now with an active eating disorder
just based on the percentages
and probably a third of the people here
have personally dealt with an eating
disorder whether it was labeled that or
not it's rampant
they're life-threatening
they profoundly affect quality of life
I Echo the statements that have already
been made about suicide
but also
um premature Cardiac Arrest is quite
common in people who are bulimic and
it's often fatal we're talking people
who are in their teens and 20s
there are productivity issues related to
the malnutrition or the distraction of
being so obsessed and focused on the
behaviors of the eating disorder
that you can't study you can't
concentrate you can't work in the way
that you would otherwise be capable of
doing
moments in helping people with eating
disorders is when they make that
connection
a couple years ago a young woman that
I've been working with at that point for
a couple of years
and continue to work with until I
retired
she's made tremendous progress
she's a dancer
dancing was her way of being a
compulsive exerciser
she's very very smart I hope to see her
name on well I'm not going to be
specific about what kind of authorship
out of privacy but someday and say I
know that person
there was a moment where she looked at
me tears rolling down her face and said
I realized that when I eat I think
better
she didn't get that for a long time
she's a junior in college and she's on
the Dean's List so progress has been
made
um
early diagnosis markedly increased the
likelihood of a full recovery
and that I think is what ties into this
bill most specifically
it is very hard for people to ask for
help
denial is one of the psychological
components of eating disorders
both the distorted body image that
representative tear described where
people don't see themselves accurately
and even if they're not skin and bones
from a quite young age in our culture
now I believe the most recent data is
around eight years old
both boys and girls identify themselves
as more obese than what their height
weight measurements show that they are
we have a culture of fattism
we admire people who are lean
and we reward that in a variety of ways
and that is one of the pieces that leads
to distorted body image which leads to
in part causing eating disorder
behaviors
it is males and females it is all ages
all sizes
um
slip and see what else I might want to
know
many many people and this is my personal
experience but it's also very well
documented in the mental health
literature on eating disorders
recognize that they have a problem and
go years before they seek help
and many many people don't recognize
they have a problem one of the
advantages that I see I'm putting the
helpline number on ID cards is friends
will call
and when friends get more information
about the language that helps their
friends get into treatment
that's actually a pretty effective way
for young people to seek help
I've had a number of times that a person
I was treating
and it's team treatment dietitians don't
treat Eating Disorders by themselves I
should be clear about that we're always
on a team with mental health conditions
pediatrician or physician sometimes
other folks as well
many times
a patient that I was treating would say
can I bring somebody in with me
and my answer to all my patients for any
diagnosis was you can bring anybody you
want here
as the more the merrier let's all figure
this out
but in the case of Eating Disorders it
was usually that that person had a
friend they were concerned about and
they wanted that friend to appreciate
that it was safe to come and talk with
me
in the hope that they would then get on
their own path to treatment
so the helpline can help
people who have a disorder and can help
folks
who would be on the support team
know how to be helpful
language is extremely important in
treating eating disorders
people often hear comments people with
eating disorders often hear comments
through their
different thought process through their
distortions
they'll hear comments that people
without eating disorders would not be
troubled by and it would not be
triggering
to somebody who doesn't have an eating
disorder
because of that language situation I
think it's particularly important when
people ask for help
that the person if they're making a call
expecting it to be professional help
that the person be very knowledgeable
about eating disorders
there is an acute shortage of therapists
who treat people with eating disorders
it is true Nationwide it is true in New
Hampshire
which means that even when you reach out
to a person who would do their very best
and has very good professional skills
to literally or figuratively talk
somebody off the ledge from suicide they
might not say what is helpful to the
person with an eating disorder
they actually might be more triggering
it also happens in emergency care
I had several patients who
went to ER usually for cardiac symptoms
sometimes for fainting episodes
lightheaded because of electrolyte
imbalances
who will have a qualified medical
provider in ER say to them Well you
certainly don't have a weight problem
that's validating to a person who has a
restrictive eating disorder
not helpful language so I don't mean to
go on and on I'm vigorously supportive
of this bill and I'm happy to answer
questions now or at any point that I
could be helpful
thank you very much representative
representative Miler thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for your
enlightening testimony
if I were to call the the help line
what would happen
what's on the other end of that Alpine
the other end of that helpline is a
trained person who knows how to listen
and what to ask to
I don't want to say minimally assessed
but it's not going to be the same
assessment as when you go into a
professional's office
but to do a basic assessment I guess is
the word I need
of what that person's needs are and
where they should be how they should be
helped
so they might be directed to
um
particular treatment facilities or
individuals in their area I believe they
do identify geographically Rosemary
maybe yeah thank you
um I'm usually on the receiving end not
the calling end
um
the idea is to get that person to have a
place where they can get help as soon as
possible and I believe there is also
follow-up to see if they did that
yes so so based upon that what you're
saying is that rather than calling a
general helpline
that would deal with the variety of
different crises
by calling this particular helpline
Theory you have that specialist who can
deal immediately with it rather than
somebody who might be in an opioid
specialist for example but not a eating
a specialist that that immediacy is
there in this helpline rather than just
a general crisis line is that correct
that is a perfect summary thank you
representative Myler thank you
so I'd like to follow up a little bit
where represent Myler was
so the person the receiving end is going
to do
then contact
those that are able to help but do we
have those resources I've had Folks up
in my neck the woods saying we have
called Hitchcock
and had no response
so do we have
the sources are the availability of
resources in this state to help those
which are dialing this number and saying
I need some help
thank you for very you're a very
excellent question
Dartmouth close their inpatient and
outpatient Eating Disorders Treatment
programs
I don't even remember exactly how long
it was ago because it's like 20 or 25
years ago
they
help people with eating disorders only
through their General psychiatric care
and they're overloaded in many ways in
that regard
we have one
um what's called an IOP intensive
outpatient program so it's many hours a
day but it's not a residential program
in New Hampshire it's right here in
Concord it's quite well respected it's a
branch of a long-established program
based in Cambridge Mass
um they generally do have availability
and they provide very good care
to different levels of care there's a
three-hour Day program in a
six or seven
I think one thing that came one
beneficial thing that came out of the
covet epidemic is a much greater
recognition that virtual treatment
sessions work for people with eating
disorders quite well
I myself did my whole practice for a
year remotely in the height of covid
I didn't want to I was skeptical that
you could developer and see what you
needed to see to be fully helpful
and
I have to say it worked as well or
better than the in-person work and so
the advantage of virtual is doesn't
matter what your ZIP code is
so when I was making a list of other
folks that people could work with as I
was retiring
it's not limited to people in New
Hampshire because you're right there's
not enough people in New Hampshire doing
this work
so it's broader
thank you
further questions
thank you very much representative thank
you
representative Howard
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee uh so I I had prepared uh some
written testimony uh that I'd emailed to
the committee a few days ago uh which I
won't bore you all with because it is
just statistics
um but as somebody who has a loved one
who has dealt with an eating disorder
this bill is something where I am asking
you all to support it because it
provides background information and gets
the gears turning in many kids heads as
representative Damon had pointed out in
her testimony uh it's something where
oftentimes it's kids helping kids it's
uh administrators helping kids in
leading them uh or suggesting to them
that they may need or want to reach out
to this National hotline uh and that is
the essence of this bill it's to provide
a and a resource that may be unknown uh
for many students
and as a student at UNH myself uh of
course because of this amendment that
they would not be printing uh the uh
hotline number or helpline number on the
back of those IDs but I still support
this bill because uh UNH and the
university system has been doing quite a
bit to try and educate the student body
about these serious illnesses
uh and uh so I'll leave it at that and
that is why I'm supporting and asking
all of you to support hb35 thank you
thank you
are there
questions of Representative Howard
thank you very much
Matthew Brown
foreign
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Matthew Brown and I
am a freshman at Merrimack high school
and I um brought this idea to
representative
um wrong originally
in the United States today 30 million
Americans have an eating disorder
whether that be bulimia binge eating
disorder or anorexia or any of the other
forms of disordered eating 30 million
Americans are suffering
as I begin I want you to try to put
yourselves in the shoes of a teenager
imagine trying to drown out feelings of
Stress and Anxiety by eating imagine
finding yourself waking up to the real
to the reality of how much you just ate
this is something that the 2.8 million
Americans who have binge eating disorder
can relate to
during the pandemic teens were left
isolated from school and friends and we
all know how much of a brown impact this
had on Mental Health
stress anxiety depression and loneliness
are all things that came out of the
pandemic and are all leading causes of
eating disorders
I like to Echo the remarks of the people
who came for me and say that
um
this issue and suicide are deeply
related if we have the ability to stop
someone who has an eating disorder from
beginning to form suicidal ideations
that is so important
um there are so many people personally
that I know who struggle with this issue
um and I'd like to touch on
um the actual helpline number I reached
out to this helpline in July and
um I can just say how helpful that this
was and how helpful I think this will be
for other students in New Hampshire
this is an issue that isn't talked about
nearly as enough as it should be but it
has to be really I think this bill will
help to give those suffering a chance
to just have a little bit of recognition
this is an issue that is deeply personal
for many people and many teens
um for that reason a lot of teens don't
think of reaching out to a professional
or talking to a parent per se about this
issue but providing those with a
discreet and easy way to find help
will be revolutionary and will truly
save lives thank you well thank you very
much Dr Brown you have a wonderful
future in front of you I can tell
um are there are there any questions of
Matthew
well Matthew yes reps and Hall
thank you chairman thank you Matthew for
taking my question so it the number was
not on the back of your card
um how did you know that there was a
number
um I struggled with a little bit of um
not to the extent of an eating disorder
but some of these issues so I I just I
Googled it
um and it took me
um a long time to find this and I'm so
proud that I was able to find this so
that other people who are struggling
more severely than me don't have to go
through such a long process to find the
help that they need thank you for the
question
thank you any other questions from the
committee yes representative luno thank
you very much Mr chairman thank you very
much Mr Brown for everyone for joining
us this morning and and really being the
Nexus on
behind this bill you mentioned 30
million Americans
that's amazing that I I had no idea
about that and and
does that compare with blood
representative Damon approximately said
yes so wow wow
thanks thank you very much thank you
thank you very much represent Woodcock
thank you Mr chairman
I even think of my question there young
man I appreciate you coming here and
your testimony has been superb you said
you would go to Merrimack High School
yes is there any your freshman right yes
have you had the opportunity to uh go
into the counseling office or the health
office and see if there are any
brochures or any other uh pieces of
commute paper like that for students uh
I have looked um briefly not for that uh
reason but I haven't seen anything
um and I think one of the reasons why
it's important to have a helpline number
on ID cards is because of how personal
this issue is and how truly traumatic
some of the experiences of people with
eating disorders can face
um so I haven't seen
uh any sort of brochures or anything on
this issue but I think that that that
would be helpful
last question
um earlier on the discussion they were
talking about text verses or text in
addition to uh would you have any
thinking on that uh
in your case if you had that card we've
had a number and a text what would you
think your preference might have been is
there a value to both so
um from what I know this helpline has
you can text it or call it in my
experience I did text and it's it's
interchangeable thank you thank you Mr
chairman thank you very much
uh she cannot ask a question
now we're just going to hang loose and
get have to go through the rest of them
further questions from the committee
well thank you thank you very very much
and Echo what reps in whitcott will said
well done
okay
um I'm gonna jump right now to Shannon
are you available right now Shannon Reed
and I I'm Scott Tom are you on the same
page I want both Tom uh Tom Crone is
from the University system Shannon reads
from the community college system in New
Hampshire
yes well Tom you're not up for it
thank you I I think it absolutely needs
to be said from from us from this table
that Matthew is just an amazing young
person and I don't know where he went
um
really just uh I'm kind of speechless
which I can't be since I'm here to
testify
um my name is Shannon Reed I'm here on
behalf of the community college system I
have handed around written testimony I'd
like to just say at the outset that the
amendment brought in by the sponsor and
100 addresses the concerns that we
raised but just to outline what those
were briefly
um
we absolutely uh believe that this bill
is is well intentioned but we think that
it's actually duplicative of what we are
are already doing in a number of ways
um last year the legislature passed
house bill
um Senate bill Senate Bill 234 which
came through this committee and it
required schools to put on their ID
cards the National Suicide Prevention
Lifeline which the community college
system
um supported and readily complied with
we put the that line and its smaller
kind of analog 998 on our ID cards this
new law became effective July 30th of
last year July 31st of last year
um in addition to putting that specific
resource information on our ID cards we
also put
the resource lines for the New Hampshire
Coalition against Domestic and Sexual
Violence and we put the crisis text line
for 24 7 mental health support and that
crisis text line incidentally does
um get you to if you if you put it into
a web browser it gets you to a page that
um that has specific a specific section
on eating disorder in addition to
depression anxiety
and some other categories of kind of
specific
concerns and it gives you the ability to
to chat uh text or communicate through
WhatsApp
um
so following the the passage of Senate
Bill 234 our system procured these new
ID cards in bulk for our seven colleges
and we probably have about two years
worth of those cards and I want to
repeat what the sponsor noted which is
these aren't cards that we print out and
laminate these are you know fairly
sophisticated digitized cards that
students use for building in room access
and meal swipes and accessing printers
and copiers so they're costly and
they're fairly sophisticated and we we
procure them from a vendor we don't make
them ourselves although we just we can
put on one side the student information
so so soon after that requirement being
adopted by the legislature we have a
supply of cards they include those three
um resource lines which we think are
applicable to a college age population
which is why we after considerable
internal discussion why we chose the
other two in addition to the suicide
prevention line that was the specific
subject of Senate bill 234. so
um I guess more broadly we just ask that
you you know you consider the role that
these credit card size cards can play
and how much information really can be
on the back along with the magnetic
strip and the thing that says Where to
return them if they're found
the colleges do per do have a lot of
other mechanisms to provide helpful
information to students we have
programming we have Outreach we have
other kinds of communications
um and so we we feel that we are kind of
comprehensively covering making sure
that students understand what resources
are available to them so I I'll stop you
have my written testimony we
wholeheartedly support the committee
Amendment commend those who brought this
idea forward and I will be happy to take
any questions or turn the microphone
over to my counterpart let's just turn
it over and then we can ask questions
and maybe either one of you can field
the question perfect uh thanks Shannon
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee Tom Cronin with the university
system of New Hampshire I would Echo
everything Shannon said both in terms of
how the university system institutions
have responded to passage of 234 last
year including both the suicide helpline
as well as in the case of the University
system local counseling lines that
students can call for other concerns
that they're having on the you know just
the Practical side similar concerns in
terms of taking these cards that mean
that really do serve many many functions
across our campuses are somewhat uh
technologically advanced and are not the
easiest to procure in the cases of for
us it's Keenum Plymouth who's similar to
the to the community college system
ordered an extended Supply they're
actually I guess unsurprisingly at this
point is a national shortage of the the
kind of cars that we use for this
purpose so I think we at least in cases
of keen and Plymouth uh would actually
have difficulty in complying with this
you know anytime in the next year or two
if we did decide to move forward uh UNH
on the flip side we actually are able to
purchase the blank cards and print both
sides as opposed to uh you know how you
saw Shannon's
um that said I do think and we talked
about this a little bit during
orientation last week in terms of you
know where some of the costs are in
higher education right now and it is
really around issues like this and it is
around our recognition of the need to
invest in counseling services resources
and the work that needs to go into
ensuring our students are aware of those
resources because as everyone before us
has testified to there are issues that
are real for our campuses and I think as
Shannon said and I would agree we we
recognize that in our working hard hard
to ensure our students are aware of the
resources and that those resources
resources are there for them when needed
so with that I will also stop and happy
to also take questions
for both of you
um in recent years last year and a half
two years here we've seen a big spike in
mental illness
IEPs associated with that and I'm sure
you're seeing that on the college
campuses as well but have you taken it
one step farther and found out that some
of that is related to the the eating
disar order
concern that we've been just addressing
today and if you have seen that what
kind of percentage are are you are you
seeing High numbers of kids in this
going in this direction or not I'd want
to be careful on on giving you numbers
but we can certainly can say in trying
to research our work around this in
preparation for this hearing is we
certainly see a link as again I think
representative Damon and others
testified to between a student's ability
to succeed on our campus and you know
healthy eating uh body image issues ETC
uh again so that is why we have in place
and continue to try to put information
out about the fact that these resources
exist
um that hopefully hit both whoever the
student who might be might be struggling
but as others had commented to their
friends and colleagues faculty
professors that they come in contact
with will know where those resources are
and try and urge them to take advantage
of looking for the community colleges I
I don't know numbers or percentage um I
did in my conversation with
representative wrong
it seemed that her information that this
this issue tends to manifest itself at
an earlier age maybe than College which
I think you know Matthew's testimony
perhaps Bears out
thank you other questions from the
committee
don't see any thank you very much
written testimony I'll hand in it is
pertinent to the underlying bill it's a
little less from the do you have
multiple copies there Tom or not okay
thank you
ollie Stevens
okay
and that we're doing right now
welcome Holly
thank you chairman Ladd members of the
committee my name is Holly Stevens I'm
the director of public policy for Nami
New Hampshire the National Alliance on
Mental Illness
um which is a non-profit Grassroots
organization whose mission is to improve
the lives of all people impacted by
mental illness and suicide through
education advocacy and support I guess
one of the blessings about testifying in
front of you towards the end is you've
heard a lot of the statistics so I'm not
going to go over a lot of them again but
I do want to reiterate
and doing some research around eating
disorders in preparation for this
hearing one of the things that we found
out through a study and I'm going to
send that study to you folks it's about
90 pages so I didn't want to make print
copies of it for everybody but I will
send it to you
that approximately 20 of those who are
diagnosed with Anna anorexia nervosa die
by Suicide
that's not 20 percent they have thoughts
of suicide or 20 percent that attempt
suicide but 20 percent that die by
Suicide this is one of the most fatal
mental illnesses
um that we have in our country today
um and uh coupled with that
um
and and the other for folks who have
um any kind of symptoms of
any eating disorder in general there are
11 more 11 times more likely to attempt
suicide so you know the suicide
connection as you've heard is uh very
strong with these folks and one of the
things that we do know is that
um the treatment resources in our state
are limited we do not have residential
or inpatient treatment at this point
um during a conversation that I had
there was a Hampstead Hospital presented
at a meeting that I was at yesterday I
brought up that fact to them to see if
they would look into maybe adding some
eating disorder treatment inpatient for
the kiddos that they bring in and they
are going to look at it but as of right
now we don't have it and so therefore
you know having this extra number on the
back of a card where you've heard you
know a kid who has an eating disorder
who is not necessarily suicidal in the
moment might look at that crisis this
number and say that doesn't pertain to
me I'm not suicidal I'm not in crisis
I just go home every night and I eat a
lot and then I throw up
and so they know they've got something
going on with their eating and so they
might look at that card and say oh
eating disorder support
and actually text or call it and I know
chairman lad you said well what if they
don't even know they have an eating
disorder and I agree with you they may
not
but for the handful of kids that do know
that this may save the life of I think
if it saves even one life of one kid in
the state it's worth putting that number
on the back of these cards so I will end
it with that
um and take any questions that you may
have I've provided my my testimony with
the rest of the statistics that um again
you've heard a lot of so I didn't want
to reiterate in oral testimony in front
of you today
thank you are there any questions yes
represent Cornell thank you thank you
for taking my question I don't know if
you can answer this the 20 that die by
Suicide is there any way to know or do
you have any statistics if they have an
underlying mental health
concern or is it because of the eating
disorder that they commit suicide or
I don't know the absolute answer to that
because again you know it was
um the statistics that I read in the
2020 study that was done by the
Strategic Training Initiative for the
prevention of Eating Disorders which I
will send to you so those stats are in
that and I'm not sure if it you know
clarified one way or the other but
during your your discussion here you may
mentioned eating and then throwing up
is there any communication being done
with Dennis obviously if something's
throwing up there must be a lot of acid
in that and that's gonna
ruin teeth and gums I would assume uh is
there any communication being done with
dentists so when they see something like
that that there can be a communication
made or discussed with the individual or
with the parent
I don't know if there's any discussions
going on with dentists I don't know if
there's anybody behind me that knows the
answer to that question representative I
think they're going like this so let's
let's hear it represent demons
um dentists are aware of this there's
actually a specific pattern of erosion
of enamel that occurs in people who are
bulimic that's different from just
regular Decay it's where the acid lands
to my knowledge there has not been it's
a really good idea
um
public education Outreach to dentists I
mean dentists could be diagnosing people
or at least referring people for
diagnosis because it is so specific
thank you thank you
further questions from the committee
thank you very much thank you
uh we have uh Becky are you going to
speak on this
okay we have two cards left
there's two cards left that means I'm
not the closer I also like you don't get
the no you don't win the prize that's
fine with me
thank you for the record Becky Wilson
from the New Hampshire school boards
Association
um we are not taking a position on this
bill I did email the committee
um some information and a cover letter
earlier today in regards to this bill
um and I certainly want to express our
support
um for the intent of this bill and to
the sponsors of this bill for bringing
this forward and to the young gentleman
who was so eloquent in speaking prior to
me on this bill as a previous District
administrator and also as a high school
administrator and a high school teacher
prior to that a person with their
license and emotional behavioral
disorders and a mother of four children
ages 17 18 19 and 21. I am deeply
entrenched in these kind of mental
health issues and struggles that follow
young people these days and it does you
know we do see it quite earlier and
earlier in our school careers as
administrators and teachers so
um but as this committee most of you
know a very similar bill was brought
forward last year by the parents of
Jason Dickey a young man who died by
Suicide well after he had left high
school but for people who were not here
he had still his school ID on him when
his parents found him and the parents
felt that had the number been on there
that perhaps he would have reached out
even though he was well past his high
school graduation year
there was concern by the committee
members and the legislators at that time
that put in the National Suicide
Prevention Hotline title on the card
might dissuade some students from
calling simply because of the stigma of
the name of that line so it was stated
in that bill that it would be listed on
the IDS as the mental health support
line so it is not listed as a Suicide
Prevention Hotline per se and at the
same time schools and districts did have
the option of listing The New National
number the 988 number which is the
national hotline for help
and we would just
um ask if the sponsors of this bill
might consider or the committee a
further consideration of an amendment to
list the 988 number it does cover an
extraordinary number of mental health
needs for students and you can certainly
look on there and see that for students
that anybody that would call it covers
addictions anxiety bullying depression
discrimination Eating Disorders family
issues Financial issues problems in
school relationship issues physical
sexual or emotional abuse physical
health self-harm sexuality somebody
else's safety violence or other all of
988 is a national number that covers all
of those things if anybody were to call
with any of those concerns and they will
then route you to the Statewide for in
our case NH 988 which would look at your
local resources
um
also of note for whatever it is worth 98
does have is open 24 7 text call or
online chatting the national Eating
Disorders Association helpline does have
more limited hours than 988 it's not
available on weekends at all for any
calls texts or online chatting it's only
open to calls from 11 A.M to 9 00 P.M
Monday through Thursday and Fridays from
11 to 5 which a lot of students that
might have access to this number are
going to be in school during those times
or in after school activities and
texting is much more limited Monday to
Thursday three to six
pm and Fridays from one to five only and
I don't know anyone who has a lot of
experience with young people or
teenagers these days but reaching out
for mental health issues can be really
overwhelming text does seem to be for
many people a more comfortable way to
start so if that is a limited option for
some of these lines depending on what is
going to be listed it may dissuade some
students if it isn't in the moment kind
of thing where they're reaching out for
help I would want something that is
available to the maximum extent possible
I think for people that age and again
this is not at all to minimize the
concerns about eating disorders in
general we certainly support the intents
of this bill overall we want all of our
kids to be able to support to access
mental health supports as needed I'm
happy to take any questions thank you
very much any questions for the school
boards Association
thank you thank you
I'd call forward representative Murphy
good afternoon chairman Ladd and Steve
members of the committee my name is
Nancy Murphy I'm a representative from
Hillsborough County District 12 the town
of Merrimack
I'm here today is co-sponsor of HP 35
and to ask for your support of this
important bill
as a society we value our children and
recognize the benefits to them
our communities and society when we
support and protect their physical and
mental health
hb35 is a tool aimed to do just that I'd
like to take this opportunity to say how
proud We are in Merrimack of Matt Brown
a 14 year old freshman who's been so
inspired to advocate for the health and
lives of his peers and has made his way
here to testify I agree with the
testimony offered earlier that students
that would be impacted by the passage of
this bill would be far more likely to
call or text a number they see a
specific to an issue affecting them in
their lives as a mother and a
grandmother and retired nurse who worked
in the Pediatric and mental health
Fields I see the Eating Disorders
hotline contact information on student
IDs as a readily acceptable accessible
tool for our children to access the help
they need increased positive Health
outcomes and save lives
not only is this bill an important way
to address the growing Health crisis
facing Our Youth and give them a fast
and convenient way to access help but it
also saves money a report by the
Strategic Training Initiative for the
prevention of Eating Disorders Academy
for eating disorders and Deloitte access
economics found that Eating Disorders
cost New Hampshire over 368 million
dollars in medical costs loss of
productivity and more passage of hb35
has potential to reduce these costs and
the negative impacts on our children's
health and lives I would urge the
committee to vote OTP and I thank you
for this opportunity to testify thank
you are there any questions for the
representative
not seeing thank you very much
are there any more any others out that
have not submitted a pink card
not seeing that we're going to close
this hearing
35 is now completed
everybody have a good weekend
drive safely home
here's the uh and and Tuesday for the
committee members don't forget we do
have a meeting at Granite State College
and there was a completed agenda put out
by the Department of Education Caitlyn
Davis so we'll be going through that
noon hour it goes to about three o'clock
with all their presentations over there
and and bring your computers because the
I platform where you're getting on and
getting all this data is going to be
explained to us and you will have an
opportunity to do it so those that are
Hands-On
yes yes yes yes
yeah represent Cornell if you have a
problem you can set aside representative
Woodcock he'll he'll he'll get you
through